[Musique]
la séance est ouverte le compte-rendu
analytique de la précédente séance a été
distribuée nous n'avons pas reçu
l'observation
il y en a-t-il en séance
je l'envoie point le procès
sous les réserves d'usage notre ordre du
jour appelle la discussion du projet de
loi d'opté par l'Assemblée nationale un
prix engagement de la procédure
accélérée relatif aux mesures d'urgence
pour la protection du pouvoir d'achat
dans la discussion générale je vais
immédiatement donner la parole Monsieur
Bruno Le Maire ministre de l'économie
des finances et de la souveraineté
industrielle et numérique
c'est le ministre
monsieur le Président Madame la
rapporteur général madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
ce matin pour vous présenter avec
Olivier dussobe les principales mesures
de ce paquet pouvoir d'achat qui
comporte un projet de loi et un projet
de loi de finance
rectificatif son objectif et je n'aurai
de ces de leur rappeler au Sénat comme
je l'ai fait à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est de protéger nos compatriotes face
à une augmentation des prix qui n'a pas
d'équivalent depuis plusieurs années et
qu'il est toujours leur vie quotidienne
augmentation du prix des carburants
augmentation des prix de l'alimentation
la vie chère est une souffrance pour des
millions de nos compatriotes et un
facteur d'inquiétude profond
nous avons apporté des réponses avec le
Premier ministre la première ministre et
le président de la République il y a
plusieurs mois en engageant des mesures
sur l'électricité sur le gaz en
plafonnant les prix d'électricité en
gelant les prix du gaz et en mettant en
place un bouclier énergétique qui a
permis de contenir l'augmentation de
l'inflation je rappelle qu'à l'heure où
je vous parle l'inflation en France est
la plus faible de tous les pays de la
zone euro mais face au Pic
inflationniste nous devons prendre de
nouvelles mesures qui continuent à
protéger dans ce pic impressionniste nos
compatriotes
ces mesures elles doivent obéir à une
vision politique s'agit pas de prendre
des mesures au petit bonheur la chance
il s'agit de répondre aussi à des
orientations politiques que je voulais
vous présenter ce matin
la première orientation c'est la
valorisation du travail
nous estimons que la meilleure réponse
au problème de pouvoir d'achat c'est la
valorisation du travail et la
reconnaissance de tous ceux qui
travaillent je sais que c'est important
pour beaucoup de groupes ici
nous continuerons donc à valoriser le
travail avec le triplement de la prime
Peppa que nous vous proposons de porter
à 6000 euros avec le soutien à
l'intéressement à la participation et je
considère que tous ces dispositifs là
doivent être soutenus massivement dans
les mois qui viennent avec la baisse des
cotisations sociales pour les
indépendants avec la revalorisation de
la prime d'activité de 4% ou la
revalorisation du point d'indice des
fonctionnaires prévus à
3,5%. nous avons ajouté à ces mesures un
certain nombre de propositions qui ont
été formulées par des députés lors de la
discussion à l'Assemblée nationale
d'autres groupes que le groupe
majoritaire je pense à la modétisation
des RTT qui me paraît une très bonne
mesure et qui était ajoutée à l'occasion
des débats à l'Assemblée nationale je
pense également au déplafonnement des
heures supplémentaires qui étaient
portées de 5000 à 7500 euros et je sais
que certains veulent graver dans le
marbre ces deux mesures
des RTT et déplafonnement de 7000 à 7500
euros des heures supplémentaires cela me
semble une idée judicieuse vous avez
également des propositions sur la
désocialisation des heures
supplémentaires pas simplement la
défiscalisation je crois qu'il faut que
nous ayons une discussion constructive
sur ce sujet en faisant très attention
de cibler les petites et les moyennes
entreprises je crois que dans ce cadre
là nous devrions pouvoir trouver des
avancées ensemble
nous avons également dans ce paquet
pouvoir d'achat décider le maintien du
bouclier énergie au moment où le prix du
gaz et le prix de l'électricité n'ont
jamais été aussi élevé il nous paraît
essentiel avec le président de la
République et avec la première ministre
et d'isabeth borne de maintenir le gel
du prix du gaz et de maintenir le
plafonnement du prix d'électricité à 4%
jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2022 je veux
redire qu'il y aura aucun rattrapage sur
2023 sur la facture des consommateurs
nous avons par ailleurs trouvé un
compromis à l'Assemblée nationale sur le
fioul et ce sont les députés d'autres
groupes que le nôtre qui ont insisté sur
la nécessité de mieux prendre en compte
le coût pour les Français qui doivent
remplir leur cuve à fuel aujourd'hui qui
voit le prix du fioul augmenter voire
augmenter drastiquement donc nous avons
adopté une aide de 230 millions d'euros
pour tous nos compatriotes qui utilisent
ce combustible pour se chauffer tout en
prenant aussi des mesures pour accélérer
la transition et permet à chacun de
changer sa chaudière mais enfin une
chaudière ça se change pas en deux
semaines il faut remplir sa cuve tout de
suite le coup il est immédiat donc nous
avons accepté cette mesure à 230
millions d'euros et j'ai indiqué que
lors des débats au Sénat nous lévrions
le gaz sur cette aide à tous nos
compatriotes qui se chauffent au fioul
parce que c'est une mesure d'urgence et
que nous voulons aussi répondre aux
situations d'urgence auxquelles nos
compatriotes sont confrontés sur le
carburant je reviens simplement sur
l'histoire de cette aide au carburant
nous avons voulu mettre en place une
remise de 18 centimes d'euro par litre
nous avons ensuite proposé que ce
substitut à cette aide une aide plus
ciblée pour les salariés c'était
l'indemnité compensatrice pour les
travailleurs
des groupes à l'Assemblée notamment le
groupe les républicains ont estimé que
cette mesure était trop complexe et
qu'il fallait une mesure plus simple et
plus massive nous avons donc trouvé un
compromis avec le groupe des
Républicains en portant la remise de 18
centimes à 30 centimes d'euros par litre
à compter du 1er septembre nous avons
donc adopté une remise de 30 centimes
d'euros par litre au 1er septembre 30
centimes en Octobre 10 centimes en
novembre 10 centimes en décembre cette
aide je le rappelle sera complétée par
les remises qui sont faites soit par les
distributeurs soit par les pétroliers
notamment total 20 centimes d'euros par
litre à partir de 1er septembre toutes
ces mesures au bout du compte ce que
nous nous faisons négociations et nos
discussions mais je pense que nos
compatiales qui nous écoutent la seule
chose qui regarde c'est à combien va
être le prix du litre d'essence ou de
diesel à la rentrée et bien si on
accumule tous ces mesures nous pouvons
avoir un prix de de naissance ou de
diesel à la rentrée autour de 1 euro 50
et je pense qu'il y a que ça qui compte
pour nos compatriotes et que tous nos
débats sont très constructifs et très
utiles mais au bout du compte la seule
chose qui compte c'est la vie de nos
compatriotes et elle sera améliorée par
cette mesure qui portera le prix de
l'essence ou du diesel à environ un euro
50 je souhaite donc je le dis avec
beaucoup de clarté que nous puissions
préserver ce compromis et que nous nous
rouvrions pas à nouveau cette question
des carburants tout simplement ce que
nos compatriotes ont entendu que
l'essence pouvait être à un euro 50 à la
rentrée je pense que revenir là-dessus
causerait plus de difficultés à nos
compatriotes qu'autre chose enfin je
rappelle que les parlementaires ont été
sensibles à la situation des petites
stations services rurales à leurs
clients ils ont proposé un
accompagnement de 15 millions d'euros
pour les petites stations services
rurales à la fois pour les accompagner
et pour les aider à se transformer je
pense que c'est une bonne mesure je
souhaite là aussi que nous la maint
je sais que certains groupes au Sénat
estiment que ce n'est pas suffisant et
qu'il faudrait rajouter à ces mesures
une taxation sur les super profits je
veux redire
je veux redire mon opposition à toute
nouvelle taxe dans notre pays pour des
raisons très profondes
pour des raisons très profondes
je sais bien que de notre pays dès qu'il
y a une entreprise qui réussit le
réflexe pavlovien c'est de lui dire il
faut immédiatement la taxer
je considère que dans un pays la France
où le niveau de prélèvement obligatoire
et le plus élevé de tous les pays
développés la bonne voie suivie des
pastels de l'augmentation des impôts des
taxes ou des prélèvements obligatoires
mais celles de la baisse des taxes des
impôts et des prélèvements obligatoires
une taxe n'est pas une réponse à la
situation économique de notre pays et je
trouve aussi que taxer des entreprises
nationales n'est pas la meilleure façon
de renforcer notre économie notre
capacité à créer de la richesse notre
capacité à créer des emplois et les
mêmes qui réclament des taxes
aujourd'hui c'est des entreprises qui
sont bénéficiaires ne s'alarmaient pas
quand ces mêmes entreprises
connaissaient des difficultés
économiques accumuler des pertes et
avait du mal à investir j'estime donc
j'estime donc que nous devons tenir
notre ligne qui est une des lignes
directrices de cette majorité baisser
les impôts et ne pas considérer que les
taxes sont les solutions aux difficultés
des Français et puis je reviens à nos
compatriotes vous pouvez vous faire
plaisir en réclamant des taxes mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs moi je
préfère faire plaisir à nos compatriotes
en obtenant des remises qui vont
directement dans leur poche plutôt que
dans la poche du Trésor public et ça
restera ma philosophie et ma ligne de
conduite
nous proposons enfin la suppression la
contribution sur l'audiovisuel public
Vous voyez toute la différence nous nous
proposons les baisses de taxes et les
baisses d'impôts et nous persistons dans
cette ligne en proposant la chute
pression de la contribution sur
l'audiovisuel public qui rend 138 euros
de pouvoir d'achat à chaque ménage parce
que c'est une suppression de taxes et
une suppression d'impôt
enfin j'imagine que bien volontiers que
un des sujets de discussion important
que nous aurons dans cette hémicycle
sera de répondre aux inquiétudes des
collectivités locales
je veux déjà souligner que à
l'initiative de Madame Christine pires
Beaune du groupe socialiste les députés
preuves d'ailleurs que nous avons trouvé
des compromis avec tous les groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale et pas uniquement
avec un seul groupe nous avons retenu la
proposition de Madame Christine
pirèsvauxne mais c'est un fait et comme
dirait quelqu'un que vous admirez
certainement beaucoup sur les bancs de
cette assemblée les faits sont têtus et
les faits prouvent que nous avons retenu
l'amendement de Madame Christine Pirès
bonne 180 millions d'euros de
dispositifs ciblés qui s'adresse au plus
de 6000 communes en difficulté qui font
face à la hausse du prix d'énergie et à
la hausse du point d'indice et 120
millions d'euros pour compenser la
hausse du RSA au niveau des départements
et je veux dire devant cette assemblée
que le gouvernement Olivier du soft
Gabriel Attal moi-même sommes
particulièrement attentifs à la
situation des collectivités locales
toute la difficulté on le connaît c'est
de savoir établir un diagnostic qui soit
le plus précis possible la situation de
ses collectivités locales et puis pardon
de le dire avec autant de franchise il
n'est pas mauvais non plus de tenir
compte de la bonne ou de la mauvaise
gestion de ses collectivités locales il
me paraît essentiel de soutenir les
collectivités locales qui ont des
difficultés qui ont eu une bonne gestion
mais ce ne doit pas être les communes
qui ont une bonne gestion qui payent
pour les communes qui ont eu une
mauvaise gestion
[Applaudissements]
les textes nous vous présentons
proposent également
des crédits pour reprendre le contrôle
d'EDF notre service public de l'énergie
à 100%. EDF est un outil industriel
fondamental pour la provisionnement
énergétique et la souveraineté de notre
pays mais EDF est face à des défis de
modernisation important l'augmentation
la demande d'électricité l'impératif de
produire une énergie décarbonée la
nécessité absolue de relancer le
programme nucléaire comme la proposer le
président de la République à Belfort
avec la réalisation de six nouveaux
réacteurs EPR pour cela nous avons
besoin d'une unité de commandement total
sur EDF c'est l'objectif de cette
nationalisation que nous vous demandons
d'approuver
enfin je rappelle que dans ce paquet
pouvoir d'achat au-delà des mesures pour
nos compatriotes au-delà de la
nationalisation d'EDF vous avez
également 12 milliards d'euros de crédit
ouvert afin de prendre en compte
l'augmentation de la charge de la dette
nous avons 10% de la dette française qui
est indexée sur l'inflation et dans ces
pour cent deux tiers qui sont indexées
sur le niveau moyen d'inflation de la
zone euro qui est plus élevée que le
niveau d'inflation en France le résultat
c'est 12 milliards d'euros de charges de
la dette supplémentaire tout cela
m'amène à redire avec beaucoup de
gravité
que chaque euro compte et que le
rétablissement des finances publiques
françaises n'est pas négociable il est
engagé le président de la République a
fixé un calendrier 3% déficit en 2027 et
amorcer la baisse de la dette publique à
partir de 2025 je suis le garant du
respect de cet engagement du Président
de la République du retour à l'équilibre
de nos finances publiques nous devons
donc dans nos débats faire attention à
ce que chaque euro soit bien employé et
je constate que l'ordre de débats
l'Assemblée nationale et Dieu sait que
le combat a été rude pour les députés de
la majorité pour les députés qui
voulaient refuser la dérive de nos
comptes publics pour les ministres au
bon du gouvernement nous avons réussi à
maintenir le cap nous sommes entrés dans
le débat avec 20 milliards d'euros de
proposition d'être supplémentaires pour
nos compatriotes
nous avons eu des dizaines et des
dizaines d'amendements représentant des
dizaines de milliards d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires de manière je
le dis irresponsable par rapport à nos
finances publiques nous sortons de
l'Assemblée nationale avec un texte qui
engage précisément
350 millions d'euros de dépenses
supplémentaires cela me paraît
responsable et cela me paraît
raisonnable mais je souhaite pour fixer
le cap à l'issue de nos débats au Sénat
nous puissions avoir des augmentations
de dépenses qui soient comparables de
l'ordre de 350 millions d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires ce qui nous
amènerait un paquet pouvoir d'achat qui
de 20 milliards passeraient à 20
milliards et 700 millions d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires pourquoi ce
chiffre-là va tout simplement parce
qu'il nous permet de tenir de 5% de
déficits publics en 2022 et que je crois
qu'il est essentiel en matière de
finance publique d'avoir des lignes
claires d'avoir des objectifs chiffrés
notre objectif dans la majorité pour le
président de la pour la première
ministre et pour le ministre des
Finances c'est de tenir les 5% de
déficit public en 2022 cela doit nous
amener à 700 millions d'euros de
dépenses supplémentaires dans le paquet
pouvoir d'achat ni plus ni moins voilà
les grandes lignes que je tenais à vous
présenter ce matin mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs je crois qu'il est
essentiel que nous ayons un débat serein
approfondi comme nous les avons toujours
dans cette hémicycle et je vous en
remercie je rappelle les grandes lignes
politiques qui sont au cœur de ce projet
de loi pouvoir d'achat la question de
l'énergie qui est essentielle la
valorisation du travail qui est
absolument fondamentale la protection
des collectivités locales face à
l'inflation parce qu'elles sont touchées
elles aussi voilà ce dont nous allons
débattre dans les jours qui viennent je
vous remercie merci monsieur le ministre
[Applaudissements]
je donne la parole maintenant à Monsieur
Olivier du socle ministre du Travail du
plein emploi et de l'insertion
autant d'outils pour lesquels le
gouvernement n'a pas besoin de
solliciter du Parlement une autorisation
législative particulière les textes que
nous vous présentons en vocation à la
fois à mettre en place de nouveaux
outils en matière de pouvoir d'achat ou
tir en matière de partage de la valeur
et de revalorisation des revenus du
travail ou qui en matière d'énergie ou
de logement que d'autres de nos
collègues viendront défendre devant vous
ils ont vocation à prévoir les crédits
et les dispositions fiscales nécessaires
à la mise en oeuvre de ces mesures c'est
l'objet du plf.r l'occasion bien sûr de
trouver avec ces différentes
dispositions une cohérence pour que
l'ensemble de ces mesures soient les
plus efficaces possibles le premier
texte qui porte différentes mesures de
protection du pouvoir d'achat des
Français va donc voir son examen débuté
par votre assemblée ce matin il a un
certain nombre d'items qui sont
spécifiquement concernés autour orientés
pardon autour du partage de la valeur et
des revenus du travail
le texte issu de l'Assemblée nationale a
été enrichi durant son examen en
commission ici même et je tiens avant
tout à saluer la qualité de ses travaux
en précisant d'emblée que nous ne
proposerons pas de revenir sur la
plupart des modifications apportées en
commission et qui améliore de manière
extrêmement nette le texte qui vous est
à cet instant soumis je pense aux
différentes modifications intervenues à
l'article 2 qui concerne les
exonérations de cotisations pour les
travailleurs indépendants je pense aux
propositions en matière de déblocage
d'épargne salariale ou encore à
certaines propositions permettant de
clarifier le cumul emploie retraite pour
un certain nombre d'hommes et de femmes
qui occupent des fonctions des lieux
locaux je voudrais à l'occasion de cette
intervention luminaire m'arrêtait sur
peut-être les trois points de divergence
ou de débats qui peuvent subsister au
sujet des six premiers articles du texte
entre le gouvernement le texte adopté à
l'Assemblée nationale et le texte adopté
par votre commission
nous avons trois points de divergence et
le premier porte sur la pérennité de la
prime de partage de la valeur pour les
entreprises de plus de 50 salariés tels
que prévu à l'article 1 ainsi rédigé par
votre commission vous le savez le
président de la République s'est engagé
à tripler la prime de joueurs d'achat en
tripler des plafonds les entreprises
pourront donc verser une prime de 3000
euros voir 6000 parents et par salarié
exonérés de cotisation sociale et le
passage de 3000 à 6000 euros de plafond
sera
arrêtée conditionné par la signature
d'un accord d'intéressement c'est une
mesure exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat
que nous voulons pour la troisième année
successive et qui concerne les salariés
percevant moins de trois fois le SMIC et
ce jusqu'à la fin de l'année 2023 nous
avons aussi souhaité tout
particulièrement après l'avis du Conseil
d'État créer un nouveau dispositif
pérenne pour ce qu'il concerne de
partage de la valeur pour toutes les
entreprises pour tous les salariés sans
plafond de rémunération assujetti au
régime fiscal et social de
l'intéressement
la commission des affaires sociales a
fait le choix de maintenir ce dispositif
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2023 et dans
réservé ensuite le bénéfice aux seules
entreprises de moins de 5 de moins de 5
ans salariés comme j'ai eu l'occasion de
l'indiquer à madame le rapporteur à
l'occasion d'une séance de travail de
préparation le gouvernement proposera le
rétablissement de la pérennité du
dispositif mais nous aurons l'occasion
de débattre de ce sujet
comme je disais il y a un instant nous
partageons l'essentiel des aménagements
apportés par la commission des affaires
sociales à la mesure de baisse de
cotisation sociale des travailleurs
indépendants prévus à l'article 2 cette
baisse pérenne se traduira par un gain
pouvant aller jusqu'à 550 euros pour les
artisans commerçants pardon pour les
professions libérales rémunérés à
hauteur du SMIC je tiens à préciser
devant votre commission qu'à la suite
des amendements adoptés les
micro-entrepreneurs bénéficieront d'un
dispositif adapté à leur spécificité et
ainsi pourront bénéficier d'une baisse
de cotisation celle-ci sera d'un montant
différent de ce qui est prévu par le
texte pour les travailleurs indépendants
puisque les modalités de calcul des
cotisations des micro-entrepreneurs sont
indépendants mais là aussi j'aurai
l'occasion d'apporter quelques
précisions lors du débat et je précise
d'emblée cependant que cet exonération
de cotisation sera intégralement
compensée à la sécurité sociale par
l'État comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
dire devant l'Assemblée nationale
pour ce qui concerne l'article 3 du
projet de loi qui propose de faciliter
le recours à l’intéressement en
particulier pour les petites et les
moyennes entreprises nous avons comme
objectif de lever un maximum de blocages
identifié comme étant des freins au
développement et au déploiement des
accords d'intéressement nous accueillons
avec
nous accueillons très favorablement
l'ajout de la commission qui prévoit de
réduire à 4 mois la durée maximale de la
procédure d'agrément des accords de
branches relatifs au dispositif de
partage de la valeur cependant j'aurai
l'occasion de vous proposer un
amendement non pas pour modifier
l'économie générale du texte adopté par
la commission mais pour préserver les
seuls délais d'opposition à la main des
partenaires sociaux c'est une demande
que je relais ici bien évidemment des
partenaires sociaux attachés à ces
délais d'opposition pour le reste les
dispositions adoptées par la commission
des affaires sociales nous paraissent
relever d'une véritable simplification
en deuxième point de divergence au sujet
des six premiers articles de ce texte
pouvoir d'achat il concerne l'article 4
que la commission des affaires sociales
a fait le choix de supprimer je vous
proposerai de
réintégrer cette article concernant la
restructuration des branches
professionnelles qui disposent de minima
conventionnels durablement inférieur au
niveau des semis c'est une mesure qui me
paraît utile je considère que l'action
combiné des partenaires sociaux et de
l'État a permis de résorber le nombre de
branches qui pourraient être
immédiatement concerné cette heureux je
pense que cette possibilité constitue
cependant pour l'avenir un outil
efficace pour empêcher que des blocages
durables et des situations durables
puissent être maintenu concernant des
bronches avec des minima conventionnels
inférieurs au niveau des semis par
ailleurs l'assemblée nationale au sujet
de cet article 4 avait adopté une
proposition permettant de réduire à 45
jours le délai imparti à la branche pour
ouvrir des négociations au lieu de 90
jours comme prévu actuellement et nous
considérons que c'est à jouer est
également utile
comme la valider la Commission le
gouvernement propose vous le savez
d'avancer les revalorisations prévues au
1er janvier au 1er avril prochain en
matière de pension de retraite et de
prestation sociale avec une proposition
de revalorisation de ces prestations à
hauteur de 4% qui s'ajoutent à celle de
1,1% pour les prestations et pensions
concernées le 1er janvier dernier et de
1,8% le premier avril dernier je précise
devant vous que toutes les prestations
seront concernées et notamment la prime
d'activité Bruno Le Maire l'a rappelé
tout à l'heure nous avons souhaité
revaloriser la prime d'activité au même
rythme que l'ensemble des minima sociaux
de manière à préserver l'écart entre les
revenus du travail au niveau du SMIC et
les revenus liés à un minima social je
ne reviens pas sur l'article 15 qui
prévoit des modalités de réembauche de
salariés dans le cadre de la réouverture
provisoire de la centrale à charbon de
Saint-Avold si ce n'est pour souligner
deux points d'abord dire cette
réouverture est temporaire en fonction
des conséquences de la guerre en Ukraine
mais dire aussi que la réembauche des
salariés concernés se fera uniquement
sur la base volontariat enfin nous avons
une troisième divergence sur laquelle je
pense que le Sénat le gouvernement et
l'Assemblée nationale peuvent travailler
la commission des affaires sociales a
adopter un dispositif d'exonération
forfaitaire de cotisation patronales sur
les heures supplémentaires dispositif
qui coûterait pour une déduction
forfaitaire de 50 centimes par heure
supplémentaires un montant total de 300
millions d'euros et donc d'un milliard 5
si cette déduction forfaitaire s'élevée
à un euro 50 nous considérons que ce
dispositif n'est pas véritablement un
dispositif de pouvoir d'achat mais un
dispositif de compétitivité nous
considérons qu'il est peut-être
éventuellement utile si les ciblé sur
les petites entreprises le ministre de
l'économie et des finances l'a dit à
l'instant nous considérons aussi que le
texte adopté par l'Assemblée nationale
pourtant loi de finance rectificatif
prévoit d'ores et déjà le relèvement du
plafond des heures supplémentaires
exonérées de 5000 à 7500 euros et afin
que le débat introduit à l'instant par
le ministre de l'économie et des
finances puissent prospérer en matière
d'exonération de cotisation sur les
heures supplémentaires j'aurais
l'occasion de vous proposer de supprimer
l'article additionnel adopté par la
commission des affaires sociales à la
fois pour que le débat ait lieu entre
aujourd'hui et le début de l'examen du
projet de loi de finance rectificatif
concernant ces sujets et pour garder à
l'ensemble de ces textes une cohérence
puisque les dispositions concernant les
offres supplémentaires sont d'ores et
déjà intégrés dans la loi de finances
rectificative pour rappel pour conclure
pardon je rappelle que ce texte qui
faisait soumis aujourd'hui prévoit aussi
une méthode et un calendrier de
décongélisation de la location adulte
handicapée je sais l'investissement et
nous avons eu l'occasion d'en débattre à
plusieurs reprises de votre assemblée
sur ce sujet notamment le rôle très
actif du sénateur Philippe mouillé nous
aurons l'occasion d'en débattre j'en
suis convaincu avec cet engagement pris
par le gouvernement de tenir un délai
maximum du 1er octobre 2023 chaque fois
que nous pourrons gagner du temps nous
le ferons sur l'ensemble de ces sujets
je forme le vœu que nos échanges
puissent permettre encore d'améliorer le
texte l'amélioration de ce texte
la meilleure la meilleure préparation et
permettant d'avoir les meilleures
conditions pour espérer qu'ensuite la
navette soit la plus productive possible
et que rapidement ce texte puisse être
adopté et les mesures mises en œuvre au
bénéfice des Français
si monsieur le ministre
je vais maintenant donner la parole
madame le rapporteur de la commission
des affaires sociales madame Frédéric
puisse
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président
messieurs les ministres madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales mes chers collègues en 2022
l'inflation devrait atteindre moins 5,5%
au niveau un niveau que la France
n'avait pas enregistré depuis 1985 nous
avions collectivement fini par oublier
les conséquences d'une forte inflation
mais celle-ci se rappelle brutalement
aux Français qui va grimper en flèche le
coût de la vie sur tous nos territoires
le projet de loi que nous examinons
aujourd'hui à justement pour objet
d'apporter une partie de la réponse des
pouvoirs publics à une très forte
demande sociale avec le collectif
budgétaire examiné en parallèle par la
commission des finances nous savons
qu'il est très attendu par nos
concitoyens or loin de répondre à cette
attente légitime nous avons déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire beaucoup des
articles du projet de loi transmis au
Sénat la semaine dernière composée un
ensemble hétéroclite ne présentant qu'un
lien tenu avec l'enjeu de préservation
du pouvoir d'achat des ménages notre a
souhaité le modifier en partant d'un
principe simple apporter une réponse
immédiate et concrète aux difficultés de
nos concitoyens face à l'inflation tout
en privilégiant à cette fin la
valorisation du travail ainsi nous avons
modifié l'article premier afin que la
prime que vous proposiez d'instaurer
messieurs les ministres permettre aux
employeurs de soutenir de façon tangible
leur salarié sans que cette prime ne se
substitue à d'autres éléments de
rémunération c'est pourquoi nous l'avons
rebaptisé prime de pouvoir d'achat c'est
aussi la raison pour laquelle nous
l'avons borné dans le temps au 31
décembre 2023 sauf pour les entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés et c'est pour ça
pourquoi également tout en permettant
aux employeurs dans fractionné le
versement dans l'année nous l'avons
limité à 4 le nombre de versements cette
même approche nous a conduit à
introduire un article premier bis qui
propose une réduction de cotisations
sociales patronale sur la majoration de
salaire au titre des heures
supplémentaires
car pour que les salariés qui le
souhaitent puissent récolter le fruit de
ce travail il faut que leur employeur
soit en mesure de les leurs payer dans
une approche de responsabilité pour nos
finances publiques cet article laisse au
gouvernement le soin de fixer par décret
le montant de la réduction
la logement des cotisations sociales des
indépendants à l'article 2 s'inscrit lui
aussi dans une logique de soutien au
pouvoir d'achat des travailleurs pour un
gains de l'ordre de 550 euros par an au
niveau du SMIC la Commission a tenu à
mieux encadrer le dispositif à en
corriger les imperfections et à en
garantir la pérennité sans oublier le
cas spécifique des micro-entrepreneurs
et monsieur le ministre vous avez abordé
le sujet tout à l'heure je regrette
toutefois l'effet de seuil lié à la
forte augmentation du taux de cotisation
prévue par le gouvernement entre 17000
et 25000 euros de revenus qui n'est a
priori pas de nature à inciter au
travail du reste les travailleurs
indépendants ne percevront les frais de
cette mesure qu'à compter du début de
l'année 2023 une échéance bien lointaine
du regard u égard à l'urgence de la
situation au travers de l'article 5 qui
prévoit une revalorisation de 4% des
prestations sociales au 1er juillet qui
je le rappelle ne constitue qu'une
avance sur la revalorisation prévue par
la loi au 1er janvier ou au 1er avril
2023 un soutien non négligeable sera
apporté entre autres à nos aînés dans le
pouvoir d'achat c'est particulièrement
érodé au cours des dernières années du
fait des différentes mesures de
sous-indexation des pensions mises en
oeuvre par le gouvernement bien qu'elle
ne suffisent pas loin s'en fout à
compenser la dégradation du niveau de
vie de retraité depuis 2017
cette revalorisation n'en est pas moins
bienvenu salut sans les autres
prestations concernées il est permis de
s'interroger et je pense que nous aurons
nous aurons l'occasion de le faire sur
l'uniformité de la revalorisation
proposée continue de l'objectif de
valorisation du travail affichée par le
texte
la Commission a par ailleurs adopté
l'article à adopter à l'article 3 qui
apporte quelques ajustements bienvenus
au régime de l'intéressement en
entreprise pour faciliter son
développement même s'il n'aura qu'un
effet très indirect sur le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés et monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez concédé lors de
notre entretien dans le prolongement des
mesures de simplification proposée nous
avons prévu également de raccourcir les
délais d'accueillement des accords de
branches sur l'intéressement et la
participation ces accords doivent être
rapidement applicables pour que les
petites entreprises les utilisent afin
de développer l'intéressement nous avons
introduit dans le texte une mesure de
déblocage exceptionnel de l'épargne
salariale qui apportera un soutien
immédiat aux salariés dans les revenus
sont insuffisants face à lauser prix ils
pourront demander jusqu'au 31 décembre
2022 le déblocage des sommes placées sur
un plan d'épargne entreprise dans la
limite de 10000 euros pour l'achat de
bien ou la fourniture de services ce
dispositif apportera un soutien immédiat
aux salariés dans les revenus sont
insuffisants face à la hausse des prix
le projet de loi apporte en revanche à
la problématique des bas salaires une
réponse peu convaincante au 1er août le
SMIC connaîtra sa quatrième
revalorisation en un an sous l'effet de
l'inflation dans ce concept dans ce
contexte et j'insiste sur ces termes
dans ce contexte de nombreuses branches
professionnelles présentent des grilles
de minima salariaux dans les plus bas
échelons sont dépassés par le SMIC afin
d'éviter un tassement des rémunérations
au niveau du SMIC l'article 4 entend
inciter les partenaires sociaux à se
saisir de la question par le biais du
processus de restructuration des
branches professionnelles il introduit
une confusion entre un chantier
structurel qui doit engager toutes les
parties prenantes et les réponses
conjoncturelles qu'elle appelle la
protection du pouvoir d'achat des
Français la Commission a considéré que
les partenaires sociaux d'une branche
éprouvant des difficultés structurelles
à négocier sur les salaires ne seront
probablement pas sensibles à la menace
d'une hypothétique fusion le surcroît ce
mécanisme qui ne concernerait que des
situations marginales
oserais-je dire extrêmement marginal
jette l'eau propre sur les branches qui
dans assume leur responsabilité dans la
situation particulière que nous
traversons la Commission a donc supprimé
cet article elle a en revanche proposée
dans un nouvel article 4 bis une
accélération des délais pour l'entrée en
vigueur et l'extension des accords
portant exclusivement sur les salaires
lorsque plusieurs réalisations du SMIC
interviennent dans la nuit ce projet de
loi sert par ailleurs de véhicules à
plusieurs dispositions visant à remédier
à certaines situations inéquitables
l'article 5 bis insérer en sciences
publiques à l'Assemblée nationale bien
clore le long débat sur la
déconjugalisation de la hache dans
lequel le Sénat a été précurseur en
particulier grâce à l'action de notre
collègue Philippe mouillé mais également
à d'autres sénateurs dans cette émission
le revirement du gouvernement dont nous
nous félicitons rend possible la mise en
oeuvre de cette réforme au plus tard le
1er octobre 2023 une date qui semble un
peu lointaine mais qui semble se
justifier par la complexité technique de
l'opération d'y revenir dans le débat
un mécanisme transitoire protège les
perdants de la réforme en leur
permettant de bénéficier de l'AAH sous
sa forme actuelle jusqu'à l'expiration
de leurs droits à la location si cette
modalité le reste plus favorable nous
attendons encore des garanties du
gouvernement et nous proposerons un
certain nombre d'amendements sur les
modalités d'application de ces
mécanismes en outre nous avons souhaité
donner une base vegan à l'instruction
ministérielle permettant au retraiter
exercer un mandat électoral local de
constituer des droits à pension de
retraite en contrepartie des cotisations
qu'il verse les élus concernées pourront
ainsi bénéficier en toute légalité des
prestations sans devoir les quitter
leurs droits auprès de l'ircanthème
enfin la Commission a première article
15 qui permet l'embauche de salariés
pour la réouverture temporelle de
centrales à charbon le cadre dérogatoire
au droit du travail ainsi prévu permet
de répondre à une situation inédite pour
notre
souveraineté énergétique tout en
assurant une protection satisfaisante
pour les salariés et l'employeur
concerné même si humidement je le dis
elle doit aussi nous interroger sur ce
que ces décisions contradictoires de la
part du gouvernement ont fait vivre à
ces territoires et les hommes et les
femmes qui sont concernés messieurs les
ministres vous l'aurez compris notre
commission s'est saisi de ce texte se
saisit de ce texte de façon à la fois
critique et constructive j'espère que le
débats permettront de l'enrichir et que
la suite de la navette lui permettra
surtout de nous montrer à la hauteur des
attentes de nos concitoyens merci
beaucoup merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Daniel Grémillet rapporteur
pour ravi de la commission des affaires
économiques
[Applaudissements]
sur un porteur
Michel président messieurs les ministres
sociales
économiques monsieur le Président
Commission en aménagement du territoire
mes chers collègues nous examinons
aujourd'hui le projet de loi pouvoir
d'achat dans une vingtaine d'articles
ont été examinés par la commission des
affaires économiques alors que nous
traversons une crise inflationniste
inédite mais prévisible notre commission
regrette le manque d'anticipation
d'évaluation et d'ambition du texte nous
déplorons aussi ces conditions d'examens
précipité alors que le gouvernement
indique vouloir bâtir une nouvelle
relation avec le Parlement c'est pas
gagné c'est pas une admissible
admissible
pour le volet énergie notre commission à
rechercher un équilibre entre la
législation d'urgence d'une part la
liberté d'entreprendre et de droit de
propriété d'autre part nous avons donc
consolider les pouvoirs de la creux à
l'égard du stockage de gaz nous avons
aussi encadré l'exercice du pouvoir de
crise du ministre est renforcé leur
indemnisation de plus nous avons associé
des collectivités à tous les dispositifs
pertinents dont l'interruptibilité du
gaz enfin nous avons circonscrit le
champ des métaniers flottants et
compléter leur programme
d'investissement gage de leur
acceptation
s'agissant de la reine qui suscite bien
des passions et à raison nous avons gelé
à 120 terawatters par an son
plafonnement est relevé à 49,5 euros
l'ensemble de son prix dans le respect
du cadre européen tout en déplorant
vivement la méthode nous avons aussi
adopté la validation d'un recours contre
l'évolution de la reine sur le plan des
consultations
pour éviter toute hausse des prix
rappelons-nous le 4 avril s'est pris
avec atteint 3000 euros mégawattheure un
record ces mesures techniques et
ponctuelles
n'éteignant rien le besoin d'une vision
politique et d'un soutien financier pour
le groupe de DF au contraire et je
souhaite vraiment le redire ici
sur le volet logement les dispositions
sur l'augmentation des loyers ou les APL
sont des solutions de court terme il
manque une réflexion de fonds et des
mesures ambitieuses montrant que le
gouvernement veut corriger le manque de
construction dans les zones tendues ou à
porter des solutions au décrochage des
aPL par rapport au charges
ceci étant notre commission a décidé
d'apporter son soutien à ce volet qui
repose sur un compromis entre l'État les
locataires et les propriétaires pour
partager des impacts de l'inflation sur
les loyers et éviter notre forte hausse
des charges des 7,4 millions de
locataires un compromis insatisfaisant
par nature mais il est équilibré et nous
voulons surtout pas le détricoter
le gouvernement propose d'une part un
plafonnement de la hausse de l'irle à
3,5% sur un an il s'agit évidemment d'un
maximum qui n'a rien d'automatique
d'autre part il soutient les ménages les
plus modestes en augmentant la même
proportion et par anticipation dès le
premier juillet deux paramètres de
calcul des aPL tout en augmentant par
décret de 4% le revenu des références
c'est révaluation bénéficieront à 90%
des 6,4 millions d'allocataires des aPL
dans des proportions variables sur le
volet consommation je regrette que nous
ayons été obligés de rester sur notre
faim le faible la faible ambition du
texte trahit le fait que le gouvernement
envisage le sujet du pouvoir d'achat
surtout et avant tout comme un sujet de
revenu est rarement un sujet de prix
notre commission c'est donc attaché à
rehausser l'ambition de cet accès à
s'assurer de son caractère opérationnel
pour tous les acteurs c'est pourquoi
nous avons prévu
que désormais tous les contrats
d'assurance concluent à distance ou par
voie électroniques devront pouvoir être
résilié électroniquement contenu de la
force de frappe des assureurs il n'y a
pas de raison de prévoir un dispositif
trop restreint à contrario afin de ne
pas pénaliser les petites entreprises
qui n'aura pas les moyens informatiques
de développer une rédigation en ligne
nous avons jugé préférable que le bouton
résiliation ne soit obligatoire que pour
les contrats déjà conclus au préalable
par voie électronique nous avons aussi
souhaité élargir le droit de résiliation
des consommateurs pour que la
concurrence les consommateurs gagnent en
pouvoir d'achat nous avons donc consacré
le principe de la résiliation à tout
moment après la première reconstruction
reconduction des contrats de service de
télévision à des vidéos à la demande
nous avons enfin jugé que les banques
devaient être davantage sanctionnées
lorsqu'elles tarte de rembourser leurs
clients victimes de fraude le schéma
graduel que nous proposons permettra de
les inciter à limiter le retard si ce
texte nous laisse le sentiment
d'innachevés notre commission appelle à
l'adopter car l'urgence doit aller au
soutien des ménages au soutien des
entreprises et au soutien des
collectivités je voudrais bien sûr
remercier Alexis Simon Laurent bétail et
Matthieu messunier ainsi Sébastien et
notre président parce que on a travaillé
dans des conditions un peu particulières
à l'ensemble des membres de la
commission des affaires économiques
merci si
je vais appeler
Bruno Belin rapporteur pour avis de la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs le rapporteur mes chers
collègues
j'ai commencé par un premier grec
j'ai vu partir le ministre de l'Économie
des Finances avant la fin de la
discussion générale
je pense que le Sénat mérite
je pense que le Sénat mérite quand même
l'écoute complète
du ministre
ceci étant dit mais chaque collègue la
commission l'aménagement du territoire
et du développement durable
et favorable à l'adoption du projet de
loi qui nous est soumise sous réserve
des modifications qu'elle lui apportait
pour les quatre articles qui relevaient
directement de ses compétences
cette validation nous l'exprimons dans
un esprit de responsabilité mais sans
enthousiasme particulier pourquoi parce
que ce texte dont le pouvoir d'achat des
Français est loin d'être la seule
finalité nous aspire malheureusement
plusieurs regrets sur le fond et sur la
forme
d'abord nous avons
collectivement regretter les délais
particulièrement contraints dans
lesquels le gouvernement nous demande de
légiférer délai qui ne sont pas indiqués
pour travailler sereinement
et je passe rapidement sur le célèbre
désormais article 21 sur l'huile de
friture adopté dans les conditions que
l'on sait à l'Assemblée heureusement le
Sénat grâce aux présidents lonjo et
Didier mandeli a pu prendre le temps de
travailler avant de débattre de cet
article
bien sûr nous n'yons pas l'urgence qui
s'attache à traiter plusieurs sujets
incontournables pour protéger le niveau
de vie des Français face à l'inflation
que nous connaissons et pour sécuriser
notre approvisionnement énergétique en
vue divers incertains qui s'annoncent
dans un contexte géopolitique tout aussi
incertain il n'empêche ce projet de loi
aurait pu et dû être mieux préparé
d'ailleurs nous avons collectivement
souligner le caractère lacunaire de
l'étude d'impact
le premier est lié au manque
d'anticipation des gouvernements qui se
sont succédés depuis 10 ans si nous
sommes aujourd'hui dans cette situation
qui nous oblige à augmenter la
production de la centrale de Cordemais
Charleroi et à redémarrer la centrale de
Saint-Avold mais aussi à mettre en place
un terminal métallier flottant raccordé
au réseau national de distribution du
gaz naturel c'est bien parce qu'il y a
eu un manque de vision stratégique à
long terme s'agissant de notre
indépendance énergétique nous avons bien
compris que sur ce sujet là chaque jour
compte et nous veillerons dans
l'intelligence de nos débats Agnès
carrier à tenir le calendrier qui est
important
au rang des décisions une opportunes je
citerai bien entendu la fermeture de
Fessenheim et le manque d'anticipation
du vieillissement de nos centrales
nucléaires
là aussi je vous renvoie à une question
gouvernement que j'ai posée ici même le
3 novembre 2021 évoquant l'erreur
Fessenheim et je crois qu'il faudrait
sous l'autorité de souffler prima et
évidemment sur les sujets énergies chers
à Daniel grimier que l'on se s'intéresse
fortement au Sénat ici à cette question
du vieillissement des centrales
nucléaires
usure incapacité aujourd'hui à tourner
la question du refroidissement est aussi
essentiel avec le réchauffement des
cours d'eau
à ces décisions notre retard sur le
déploiement des énergies renouvelables
je pense en particulier à l'éolien marin
ainsi qu'au photovoltaïques enfin ce
projet de loi comporte à mon sens un
angle mort majeur à savoir la notion de
sobriété énergétique la formule est
connue l'énergie la moins chère et celle
que l'on dépense pas alors je regrette
que le gouvernement ne présente toujours
pas un plan national complet de sobriété
qui serait le levier le plus efficace
pour protéger nos concitoyens dans à la
fois dans leur niveau de vie et et si
dans la sécurité du réseau je salue
d'ailleurs l'initiative du président
Retailleau qui a déposé à ce sujet un
amendement du reste les amendements
adoptés par la commission permis d'une
part d'apporter des garanties
complémentaires pour l'information du
public l'environnement et la santé la
santé s'agissant du raccordement du
terminal métallier flottant au Havre et
de mieux encadrer la compensation
carbone des émissions des centrales à
charbon et d'autre part commandement
adopté
en vue d'améliorer la qualité juridique
du texte voilà monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre madame la
Présidente les principaux éléments que
je souhaitais apporter à votre attention
avant d'avoir le plaisir d'en débattre
avec vous je vous remercie monsieur
je vais donner maintenant la parole à
Madame Christine Navarre rapporteur pour
avis de la commission des finances
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président moi aussi je
vais regretter le départ du ministre de
l'économie parce que mes propos étaient
finalement plus pour lui que pour le
ministre du Travail mais que j'ai
plaisir à retrouver donc la commission
des finances c'est effectivement saisie
pour avis sur le titre 20 car c'est
celui qui a l'incidence la plus forte
sur les finances publiques et c'est
aussi il nous semble le seul qui a un
véritable effet à court terme sur le
pouvoir d'achat alors nous sommes dans
une situation imprévisible puisqu'il y a
quelques mois encore la branque de
France faisait une estimation
d'inflation pour 2022 de seulement 2,5%
avec un retour sous 2% à la fin de
l'année mais tout ça c'était avant la
déclaration de la guerre à l'Ukraine
désormais l'indice des prix à la
consommation est estimé à 5,6% à la fin
de l'année 2022 mais ce qui est très
important d'avoir en tête c'est que nous
sommes face à un choc d'offres et ce
choc d'inflation à l'origine très
concentrée sur l'énergie puis sur
l'alimentation c'est désormais diffusé
sur l'ensemble du système des prix des
produits manufacturés mais aussi sur les
services avec un début d'accélération de
l'ensemble du système de prix et
d'ailleurs selon les travaux de
l'Institut exécode si jamais les prix
c'était se stabilisaient à leur niveau
de joint le choc d'inflation pour la
seule année 2022 représenterait toutes
choses également par ailleurs une charge
de 65 66 milliards d'euros par rapport à
2021 sur le revenu des ménages soit
environ 1000 euros par habitant ceci
représente aussi 43% de la surépargne
des années 2020-2021 qui se trouve des
facto réintroduites dans le circuit pour
maintenir le niveau de dépenses des
ménages alors la politique du
gouvernement menait depuis la fin de
l'année 2021 à l'origine pour répondre
aux conséquences de la reprise de
l'activité à la suite du confinement et
de la crise sanitaire à amorti le choc
en France puisque la moyenne pour
l'ensemble de la zone euro et de 1288
euros par habitant alors même jusqu'à
1450 euros par habitant en Allemagne en
effet en France la hausse des prix de
l'énergie a été fortement amortie par
les actions de l'État mais pour mémoire
avant même l'étude du PLF qui débutera
la semaine prochaine et l'étude de ce
texte déjà 18,4 milliards de dépenses
ont été engagés pour soutenir le pouvoir
d'achat des Français 4,4 milliards Opel
fr 2021 5,9 milliards devenus 8,1
milliard au PLF 2022 avec le bouclier
tarifaire 5,9 milliards dans le décret
d'avance de février pour financer le
plan de résilience économique et social
alors quelle est la pertinence de cette
politique du quoi qu'il en coûte faut-il
mieux des primes désocialisées
défiscalisées ou une hausse des salaires
alors la progression des salaires sur le
long terme est rendu possible uniquement
par des gains de productivité or on
constate aujourd'hui que les gains de
productivité sont très en deçà de la
progression du salaire réel en 2009 lors
de la crise financière la productivité a
baissé mais les salaires ont continué de
progresser et l'écart a été rattrapé
ensuite par la mise en place du crédit
d'impôt pour la compétitivité et
l'emploi est-ce encore possible
aujourd'hui non car l'état de nos
finances publiques ne permet pas de
créer un nouveau CIC
alors par ailleurs la prime peut créer
un effet d'aubaine pour les entreprises
au premier trimestre de l'année 2019
l'Insee relevé que le salaire moyen par
tête avait augmenté de 2,7%, mais
seulement de 1,3% si on y retranchait
l'effet de la prime Peppa soit un niveau
de croissance inférieur au trimestre
antérieur et au trimestre suivant ou la
hausse était plutôt de
1,5%. les entreprises ont-elles les
moyens de participer contenu compte tenu
de l'évolution de la structure des coûts
des entreprises le niveau de résultats
d'exploitation rapportait à leur valeur
de leur production recule pour rejoindre
les points bas de 2012 et de 2013 on
s'attend aujourd'hui à une réduction des
marges alors en l'état ce n'est pas
alarmant puisqu'elles étaient hautes en
2021 mais elle devrait revenir un niveau
proche de 2018 par ailleurs la
productivité a baissé depuis 2019 et
cela pose des vraies questions sur les
marges de manœuvre des entreprises pour
augmenter les salaires ou pour verser
une prime et ce n'est pas la
multiplication par 3 du plafond entre la
pépa et la PPV qui va vraiment le
permettre c'est surtout un effet
d'annonce faut-il des une intervention
ciblée ou un soutien général en mars
l'OFCE a calculé que sur cinq sur 5%
d'inflation générale les 10% des ménages
les mieux lotifs à ce choc subissent une
inflation de seulement 2,5 % là où les
10% des ménages les plus exposés
subissent une inflation de 8,5%. cet
écart se justifie moins par les revenus
que par les endroits où habitent ces
personnes puisque au sein d'un même des
styles des situations sont très
différentes suivant si on a besoin
d'utiliser sa voiture ou pas notamment
pour aller travailler et donc il est
très important de tenir compte de cette
diversité des situations face à
l'inflation pour définir la politique
publique l'inflation se nourrit en effet
également de l'afflux de liquidités et
donc la généralisation la pérennisation
d'une prime dédiée au pouvoir d'achat
contribuerait à auto-entretenir cette
inflation c'est la raison pour laquelle
la commission des finances a décidé de
recentrer le dispositif pour en faire
vraiment un dispositif de soutien en
faveur des plus modestes
[Applaudissements]
je vais donner la parole madame la
présidente Catherine de roche
merci monsieur le Président en
application de l'article 44 à Linéa 6 de
règlement la commission des affaires
sociales demande la priorité d'examen et
de vote sur l'article 15 immédiatement
après l'article 5 terres je vous
remercie la vie du gouvernement
favorable
donc la priorité est ordonnée pas
d'observation
[Musique]
bien Madame la Présidente
vous avez souhaité faire un rappel au
règlement
oui merci monsieur le Président se
rappelle au règlement et fondé sur
l'article 36 de notre règlement
de nos débats visiblement le changement
de méthode inventée par le gouvernement
c'était pas évaporé avec la canicule de
ces dernières semaines sur ce texte au
total 106 amendements ont été jugés
irrecevables soit au titre de l'article
40 soit au titre de l'article 45 vous
connaissez notre avis sur l'article 40
nous en demandons la suppression dans la
Constitution je n'y reviens pas sauf
pour quand même dire ma colère sur le
rejet de quelques amendements parmi
lesquels celui visant à rétablir la
demi-part pour pour les veuves mais
l'article Caron 5 l'article 45
franchement évidemment que nous recevons
des messages pour nous préciser le
périmètre de ce texte
je dois dire que à l'évidence ce
périmètre est assez élastique pour ne
pas dire très subjectif d'un point de
vue politique bien évidemment ainsi le
Sénat se refuse à débattre des
amendements sur la consommation sur le
blocage est prêt énergétique et
alimentaire et même les demandes de
rapport même les demandes de rapport
sont des armées rejetées donc je demande
solennellement la levée de l'article 45
sur ses amendements donc au final nous
allons prendre acte de la situation mais
je dois dire que beaucoup de voix
aujourd'hui nous parlent de recherche de
compromis pour éviter de dire de
consensus politique de changement de
méthode d'écoute etc force et de
constater que le temps d'aujourd'hui est
pire que le temps d'hier et que les
débats dans l'hémicycle au grand jour
n'ont plus d'importance à vos yeux car
vous y préférez bien évidemment
l'obscurité des CMP pour re pour régler
pardon vos affaires entre gouvernement
et majorité sénatoriale
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président je ne
reviens pas monsieur le Président sur la
priorité de demander par la commission
sinon pour dire que le Gouvernement est
favorable dans la mesure où l'article 15
concernant les conditions de travail de
réembauche des salariés de la centrale
de Saint-Avold il est
utile je crois de pouvoir l'examiner au
même moment que les autres articles
consacrés et portés par le ministère du
Travail je voudrais simplement dire
après le rappel le règlement de madame
la Présidente assassy que j'étais un peu
surpris d'entendre un lien entre la
méthode du gouvernement sur laquelle
madame la Présidente évidemment
l'évaluation qu'elle souhaite et la
question de lire recevabilité au titre
de l'article 40 et 45 l'examen de la
recevabilité dépend du Parlement et le
gouvernement en tout cas dès lors que je
le représentais ce bon ne fera jamais
aucun commentaire sur les questions d'y
recevabilité qui sont à la main des
présidents de commission et de votre
assemblée
merci
nous allons poursuivre notre discussion
générale et je vais donner la parole à
Madame Raymond de ponts et Monge pour le
groupe écologie solidarité territoire
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue le Sénat se
prononce sur un projet de loi de
protection du pouvoir d'achat face à une
situation d'inflation galopante dont la
cause principale géopolitique serait
exceptionnelle voire temporaire or si le
choc est bien exogène la gravité de son
impact notamment pour nos
approvisionnements en énergie découle
d'abord du retard pris quant à la
transition énergétique aujourd'hui cela
nous condamne à une fuite en avant avec
le nucléaire à la réouverture de
centrales à charbon véritable bombe
climatique voire au recours au gaz de
schiste importé que les choses soient
claires la remise en service d'une
centrale à charbon la mise en place de
terminaux métalliers ne peuvent être des
réponses durables quand l'urgence est de
sortir des énergies fossiles par le
maintien de notre dépendance au gaz et
au pétrole nous payons le prix le prix
fort de la plus grande illusion de notre
temps celui d'une énergie abondante sans
impact et peu cher aujourd'hui c'est une
économie au service de la construction
de la sobriété qui doit se mettre en
place il nous faut prendre la mesure de
la réflexion générale des ressources qui
associer au dérèglement climatique
génère une inflation tendancielle et
enfin engagée des politiques
d'adaptation car les dérèglements
climatiques comme la sécheresse provoque
régulièrement une hausse des prix ainsi
le manque d'eau a détruit au moins un
tiers de la récolte saisonnière de riz
de maïs et d'alimentation animale en
Italie les plans de blé sont si dévastés
en Inde que le pays interdit toute
exportation en décembre dernier un
rapport de la BCE concluait que le
dérèglement climatique avait un impact
non négligeable sur la hausse des prix
des produits agricoles et la Banque de
France se renchérit une transition
tardive et désordonnée aurait des effets
défavorables
matin 10 à 20% du PIB mondial à la fin
du siècle de plus ce modèle économique
dixit car le Marx épuise deux choses le
travailleur et la nature et je m'en
explique car un autre facteur
d'inflation provient de l'anticipation
spéculative par les grands groupes entre
autres ceux de l'énergie et du transport
qui profite de la crise pour réaliser
des surprofies auxquelles ni le
gouvernement ni la droite non
l'intention de s'opposer enclenchant la
boucle profit pris au-delà de ces
secteurs augmentant de plusieurs points
leur taux de marge de façon générale les
grandes entreprises ne prennent pas leur
part dans la détérioration actuelle des
termes de l'échange la faisant porter
essentiellement sur les salariés en
déconnectant les augmentations de
salaire de la hausse des prix c'est se
découplage entamé depuis le tournant de
la rigueur qui a dégradé durablement le
partage de la valeur ajoutée alors que
depuis 2017 les réformes antisociales et
de baisse des contributions des
entreprises continuent de déformer le
partage du PIB au détriment du facteur
travail l'inflation actuelle nécessite
pour ne pas aggraver la crise sociale
des mesures ciblées des mesures durables
de soutien notamment pour les catégories
populaires puisque l'inflation les
frappes davantage du fait de la
structuration de leur consommation et la
part des dépenses contraintes
préengagées à l'opposé de quoi nous
avons des primes ponctuelles des
socialisés d'infiscaliser asséchant le
salaire socialisé le seul générateur de
droits contributifs coûteuse pour les
finances publiques et le système de
protection sociale qui a la star des
principales des précédentes primes ne
concernent qu'une entreprise sur six en
France une entreprise sur ils ont les
TPE mais plus de la moitié des
entreprises de plus de 1000 une prime
d'autant plus importante que le secteur
présente de fortes rémunérations en
conclusion un dispositif inégalitaire
pour une minorité de salariés à
croissant toujours plus la part variable
de la rémunération et freinant
substituant aux augmentations générales
de salaire le partage de la valeur de la
valeur ajoutée n'est pas une question de
prime d'abord n'est pas une question
d'intéressement mais d'abord une
question de salaire ce qui manque à ce
projet de loi
ce sont des solutions durables tant pour
la transition écologique que pour
protéger les plus vulnérables dont les
jeunes dont je vous rappelle sont
oubliés une fois de plus dans ce projet
du fait des nombreuses y recevabilités
il nous est 40 et 45 effectivement il
nous faisait impossible de la monder en
ce sens aussi la totalité du groupe
écologiste votre acompte je vous
remercie merci
[Applaudissements]
que donner maintenant la parole à notre
collègue Cathy à Boursault poli pour le
groupe communiste républicain citoyen et
colchistes vous avez la parole ma chère
collègues
dans quelques instants
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues tout ça
pour ça alors que nos compatriotes
voient le coup de la vie flambée tandis
que les salaires n'augmentent pas que
les collectivités subissent de plein
fouet l'augmentation du prix de
l'énergie comme celle des matériaux vous
nous présentez aujourd'hui un projet de
loi du pouvoir d'achat qui n'en a que le
nom face à la montée des prix de
l'essence des denrées alimentaires des
loyers et des transports le gouvernement
a décidé de répondre par des mesurettes
qui ne remettent absolument pas en
question le choix de fond que sont les
cadeaux aux plus grandes entreprises
faut-il vous rappeler que la France et
la championne des dividendes en Europe
avec
54,6 milliards d'euros vous qui faites
le choix des
incitations à verser des primes et à
sortir le chétier plutôt que des
augmentations de salaires pérennes alors
oui c'est déjà ça pour un ton dire il y
a quelques avancées pour les Français
comme la valorisation 4% des minima
sociaux des prestations sociales et la
revalorisation 3,5% du point d'indice
des fonctionnaires qui est gelé depuis
des années ces dispositions sont
d'ailleurs les seules véritables mesures
du pouvoir d'achat du texte mais qui
demeure en dessous du niveau d'inflation
qui était de 5,9 en juin et qui devrait
atteindre les 7 % en septembre ces
mesures sont d'autant plus insuffisantes
que selon l'Insee elle ne permettront
d'améliorer le revenu disponible des
ménages que d'un point vous parliez d'un
bouquet de mesures qui s'apparentait au
bouquet de la mariée finalement ce sera
un bouquet de chrysanthèmes vous vous
entêtez dans une logique libérale du
laisser faire des entreprises en
facilitant le versement de prime
défiscalisée et exonéré de cotisations
sociales avec ce système les patrons
seront incités à accorder des primes
plutôt qu'à augmenter les salaires c'est
d'autant de manque à gagner pour les
contes de la sécurité sociale il n'y a
aucun changement de braquet dans la
répartition des richesses juste un tour
de passe-passe qui prend tout la
sécurité sociale pour donner avec
parcimonie à quelques-uns les seuls
gagnants sont les entreprises en
définitive encore une fois si je peux me
permettre cette affaiblissement
programmée des comptes de la Sécurité
sociale
justifiera d'ailleurs demain la
nécessité de réformer notre système de
retraite et de réduire les droits des
salariés à travers une future réforme de
l'indemnisation chômage la droite
sénatoriale partage cette vision
puisqu'elle a ajouté un article premier
bus qui prévoit la défiscalisation et la
suppression des cotisations sociales sur
les heures supplémentaires même en cas
de compensation des exonérations par
l'État vous priver en réalité les
services publics de moyens pour ne
donner qu'un exemple alors que les
hôpitaux sont en train de fermer leur
service d'urgence faute de personnel
vous prévoyez d'amputer le budget de
l'Assurance Maladie de 500 millions
d'euros supplémentaires sur les
travailleurs indépendants ces mêmes
hôpitaux devront également payer les 2
milliards d'euros de revalorisation du
point d'indice des agents hospitaliers
quand les collectivités devront payer
les 2,3 milliards d'euros de
revalorisation du point des agents de la
fonction publique territoriale seule
véritable satisfaction de ce texte la
déconjugualisation de l'adulte de
l'allocation adulte handicapée que nous
avions porté ici au Sénat dès 2018 à
l'époque ni le gouvernement ni la droite
n'en voulait
oui c'est vrai ça ne vous fait pas
plaisir mais c'est vrai aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le sujet fait l'unanimité
face à l'urgence sociale les familles ne
peuvent pas attendre le 31 octobre 2023
il faut arrêter l'hémorragie à la CNAV
qui voit la réduction de son budget de 5
% par an et qui a vu 2000 emplois
disparaitre et remettre des moyens
humains en face des besoins cette une
urgence les mesures concernant la
souveraineté énergétique la sécurité
d'approvisionnement en électricité ou le
transport routier de marchandises semble
bien éloigné du pouvoir d'achat et ne
vont pas réduire les factures des
familles il nous faut des mesures
structurelles fortes comme
l'augmentation des salaires et pensions
augmenter le SMIC à 1500 euros ou
revaloriser 10% le point d'indice des
fonctionnaires nous avions de nombreuses
propositions alternatives tombées sous
le coup de l'article 40 celle-ci mettait
à contribution les profiteurs de crise
pour une société plus juste vous savez
les entreprises du CAC 40 monsieur le
ministre qui ont dégagé des profits de
record de près de 160 milliards d'euros
en 2021 ce à qui vous avez déjà supprimé
l'ISF le groupe kaministre républicain
citoyen écologiste refusent de soutenir
des revalorisations inférieures à
l'inflation financée exclusivement sur
le dos de la sécurité sociale sans
mettre à contribution les entreprises et
les revenus financiers je vous remercie
et comme la période de vacances est
souvent propice à la lecture monsieur le
ministre je vais vous laisser nos 50
mesures pour un véritable bouclier
fiscal
merci
je vais donner la parole à notre
collègue Jean-Marie van perenberg pour
le groupe de l'Union centriste
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
sur le président
monsieur le ministre je salue votre
présence constante d'ailleurs en ces
lieux depuis des années madame la
Présidente de la Commission madame la
rapporteur messieurs des rapporteurs mes
chers collègues l'inflation
galopante de ces derniers mois qui est
dû bien sûr pour une bonne part à la
flambée du secteur énergétique
alimentaire nous ramène brutalement
quelques années en arrière dans les
années 70 et 80 que j'ai malheureusement
bien connu le problème c'est qu'à cette
époque nos concitoyens sortaient je
dirais du plein emploi des trentes
glorieuses et qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup
beaucoup trop ont connu l'épreuve du
chômage la galère je dirais et plus
fragile d'entre nous
ont donc besoin de solidarité alors le
titre de ce projet de loi marque et je
m'en félicite une ambition
protéger le pouvoir d'achat des Français
d'aucun pourrait regretter qu'il ne
l'améliore pas je regrette pour ma part
que nous ne parlions pas à cet instant
plus volontiers de pouvoir de vivre avec
une pensée émue vous vous me pardonnerez
pour la disparition brutale d'un
secrétaire confédéral de la CFDT
Frédéric Seb que nous sommes plusieurs
d'entre nous ici avoir bien connu au
corps et que nous regretterons le temps
il manquera au dialogue social notamment
sur les retraites
ceci étant l'Union centriste considère
que ce texte va dans le bon sens
et nous le soutiendrons je salue
d'ailleurs le travail de nos rapporteurs
qui ont éclairé nos débats tout en
sécurisant le texte évidemment les
moyens dont dispose le gouvernement ne
serait contraintes des employeurs à une
augmentation des salaires hors SMIC il
s'agit là de les aider en luttant contre
l'inflation économique voire aussi
démagogique l'article premier vient donc
tripler le plafond de la prime
exceptionnelle de pouvoir d'achat de
remarques en ce sens par principe c'est
le ministre nous ne souhaitons pas que
des dispositions exceptionnelles soient
pérennisées mais en pratique nous
pensons que l'intéressement contre comme
la participation à l'entreprise doivent
être encouragés voir facilité si la
corde intéressement reste une condition
pour accorder cette prime dans les
entreprises de moins de 50 salariés les
contrôles aléger la capacité de
l'employeur à prendre un accord
unilatéral sont bienvenus il serait
préjudiciable de s'en passer
l'article 2 n'appelle pas d'observation
particulière et nous accueillerons
favorablement la baisse des cotisations
sociales pour les travailleurs
indépendants sur l'article 3 qui tente à
favoriser l'intéressement notre
commission a permis d'assimiler les
périodes de congés paternité à une
présence en entreprise pour son calcul
elle a également limité à 4 mois la
durée de la procédure d'agrément et des
accords de branche soit relatifs à
l'intéressement à la participation à
l'épargne salariale ces deux points
méritent soutenus et nous serons
vigilants d'ailleurs en CMP concernant
l'article 4 notre rapporteur a présenté
un amendement suppression en commission
et le gouvernement nous propose de le
réintroduire j'entends bien que
l'article serait peu opérant mais
j'entends aussi du gouvernement que 17
branches
serait concerné depuis le 1er octobre
après la revalorisation du SMIC nous
attendons donc beaucoup de ces échanges
monsieur le ministre et Madame la
rapporteur pour nous positionner sur ce
point l'article 5 prévoit la
revalorisation par anticipation des
retraites et des prestations sociales
nous soutiendrons évidemment ces
dispositions mais je veux dire ici notre
position à toute tentative d'une
revalorisation orabée notamment pour le
RSA
précisons que le droit prévoyait ses
revalorisations et donc le gouvernement
permet de faire par anticipation sans
dépasser ce qui aurait été dû c'est bien
l'esprit de ce test
je terminerai enfin par l'article 5 bis
s'agit là de mettre fin à une injustice
sociale en décongè en déconjugalisant
par Don la hache et je salue
effectivement tous ceux qui ici comme
Philippe mouillé et les sénateurs
communistes hommes aussi certains
députés ce sont battus pour l'obtenir il
serait temps de railler évidemment la
volte-face du gouvernement où sa défaite
j'y vois plutôt le signe d'une bonne
santé parlementaire et que nous sommes
toujours en régime parlementaire et j'y
vois aussi peut-être l'espoir monsieur
le ministre que la concertation l'écoute
et la négociation avec le Parlement
deviendront la règle en conclusion et
sous ses réserves le groupe de l'Union
centriste soutiendra ce texte
merci
chersbanel pour le groupe du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen
la parole
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs madame la
Présidente de la Commission
les Français sont dans le rouge plus de
5,8% d'augmentation des prix en juin et
ce n'est pas terminé pour faire face à
ce plus haut niveau d'inflation jamais
atteint depuis novembre 1985 il fallait
réagir vite c'est ce que propose le
paquet législatif pouvoir d'achat et
pelle à faire les jinges sont clairs
protéger le niveau de vie le reste à
vivre relancer la consommation faire
face à une crise énergétique également
sans précédent le tout dans un contexte
géopolitique dramatique avec la guerre
en Ukraine
mon groupe le RDC souhaite d'abord
souligner les effets positifs du texte
présenté par le gouvernement par exemple
la revalorisation de 4% des pensions de
retraite et d'invalidité des prestations
familiales des minima sociaux et des
bourses étudiantes à cela s'ajoute la
revalorisation du point d'indice la
fonction publique de 3,5% prise par
décret cela va initier un coup de pouce
notable immédiat nous devons souligner
aussi l'adoption de la mandement dans le
PFR qui a permis de compenser la hausse
du RSA par une dotation de 120 millions
d'euros départements et celui qui
apportera de l'aide à certaines communes
nous sommes plus réservés sur l'article
1 une prime c'est bien une augmentation
de salaire c'est mieux en effet si 20%
des salariés ont bénéficié de cette
prime le versement moyen est de 546
euros au lieu des 1000 euros possible
jusqu'à maintenant
alors à quoi sert d'augmenter le seuil
sinon à se faire plaisir avec des effets
d'annonce
sur le modèle de l'article 2 qui prévoit
une exonération de charges pour les
travailleurs indépendants il aurait été
préférable de pousser plus loin les
énumérations de charge sociale ou de la
CSG pour les basses salaires
une mesure qui génèrerait un véritable
bol d’oxygène pour les ménages qui
revaloriseraient le travail cher à notre
groupe et à d'autres j'en suis sûr
sceptique aussi nous le sommes
concernant les loyers car d'un côté on a
croix de 3,5 des aPL et de l'autre on
bloque à 3 et demi pour cent
l'augmentation des loyers
certes on bloque mais cela n'évite pas
l'effet pervers mathématique
si le plus ancien groupe du Sénat ne
peut se permettre d'emprunter
l'expression d'un fumage cher à certains
députés il en pense pas moins nous
constatons que les 8 euros en moyenne à
gagner à partir de la hausse des aPL ne
compenseront jamais l'augmentation des
loyers par exemple pour un loyer de 600
euros une augmentation de 21 euros
possibles je ne crois pas que l'effort
profite à tous de la même façon de plus
quid des locataires est une touche pas
d'appel et qui ne sont pas pour autant
des lentilles nous aurions préféré
conditionner cette augmentation aux
travaux de rénovation de rénovation
énergétique nous proposerons à ce sujet
plusieurs amendements le bouclier le
bouclier loyer tel que nommé par le
gouvernement n'apparaît en effet que
comme un tout petit pare-feu
pas pu venir voir les conséquences de
cette dépendance et vous n’êtes pas les
seuls bien sûr responsables aucune
stratégie de crise n'a été
collectivement prévu rien n'a été
anticipé y compris et c'est plus grave
pour l'existant 30 réacteurs nucléaires
sur 56 sont à l'arrêtés quand on sait
que la production d'électricité en
France et dépend très largement du
nucléaire on a quelques questions à se
poser sur notre organisation et notre
gestion aujourd'hui nous demandons aux
Français de faire des efforts
d'économies de même peut-être d'arriver
à des coupures au quotidiennes cela ne
pas sérieux et se fait dans la
précipitation
concernant l'aménagement au droit de
l'environnement pour le terminal
flottant au large du Havre
même si nous comprenons l'urgence les
élus locaux qui voient leurs projets
photovoltaïques refusés souvent sous sur
d'anciennes décharges apprécieront la
dispense d'évaluation environnementale
bref la crise élogeuse ne peuvent donner
un blanc sain aux autorités publiques
côté pouvoir d'achat nous attendons plus
du paix les fer et qu'il aille plus loin
dans les mesures je ne voudrais pas
finir mes propos
en disant que la note du caddie est
salée pour les consommateurs et les
produits agricoles ne doivent pas être
la variable d'ajustement entre crise
sanitaire crise géopolitique crise
énergétique et les français payent le
prix fort de nos débats et de nos votes
dépend de leur quotidien merci
mon chers collègues
je vais appeler notre collègue Stéphane
Ravier pour la Réunion administrative
des sénateurs de figurant sur la liste
d'aucun groupe
il y avait la parole
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le
gouvernement ayant confiné tous l'été se
trouve à Fort des pourvu quand
l'inflation fut venue pas un seul petit
morceau de regain dans les hôpitaux lit
administres de la morphine au
contribuable en famille ce projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat annonce un saupoudrage
ponctuel et coûteux dans un contexte
d'inflation historique et durable une
réglera donc rien vous nous demandez
d'arroser d'une goutte d'eau la plante
dont vous avez asséché le terreau en
ayant voulu jouer au mariole avec votre
politique du coup à qu'il en coûte elle
laisse sous-entendre à tort une forme de
générosité de l'État alors que Margaret
l'a dit avant moi l'argent public
n'existe pas il n'y a que l'argent des
contribuables à l'épisode de l'argent
magique succède désormais celui de
l'appauvrissement tragique contrairement
à ce que vous tentez de faire croire la
crise Russo ukrainienne et marginale
dans l'explosion de l'inflation elle a
commencé début 2021 comme la conséquence
directe des confinements et des mois de
restriction et du recours massif à
l'usage de la planche habillée par les
banques centrales depuis nous avons eu
la hausse des prix de l'énergie du prix
à la pompe des denrées alimentaires si
vous ne voulez pas revoir les rues de
France couvertes de gilets jaunes rouges
de colère il faut agir et vite monsieur
le ministre nous pourrions par exemple
remplacer - 25 % du total de la prime de
Noël et de l'allocation de rentrée
scolaire par des bons d'achat fléchés
exclusivement envers des produits
fabriqués en France soit un milliard 250
millions d'euros pour l'emploi sans
aucune dépense publique supplémentaire
le meilleur moyen de débloquer de
l'argent pour nos compatriotes c'est
d'abord de ne pas leur prendre ce qu'ils
ont gagné mettez un terme à votre
raquette fiscale envers ceux qui
entreprennent ceux qui travaillent et
qui donc produisent de la richesse vous
qui par votre incurie énergétique vous
les rationnez les Français en énergie
commencez par rationner l'État en impôts
sobriété bien ordonnée commençant par
soi-même d'autant que l'année 2022
s'annonce anus horribilis l'explosion de
la dette va mécaniquement entraîner
l'explosion des intérêts de la dette et
qu'il nous faut payer chaque année ce
sont plusieurs dizaines de milliards
d'euros supplémentaires qui va vous
falloir trouver en augmentant les impôts
impossibles les Français ne le
supporteraient pas en rognant sur les
budgets les ministères à l'exception de
l'immigration ils sont à l'os de
l'argent pour les Français il y en a et
beaucoup je vous propose de prendre
d'urgence des mesures pour lutter contre
l'assistanat contre la fraude sociale
qui atteint 50 milliards d'euros la
fraude fiscale et ses 70 milliards et
bien sûr bien sûr le gouffre de
l'immigration qui sans parler du coût du
sang coûte sur le seul plan financier
plusieurs dizaines de milliards au
contribuable français avec 600 milliards
d'euros de dettes sous le premier
quinquennat et 10 millions de Français
qui survivent sous le seuil de pauvreté
réussir à s'en sortir seulement à s'en
sortir dans la France du Mozart de la
finance relève monsieur le ministre
chaque jour un peu plus de l'exploit ce
qui délivrer vous couvrir de honte les
français demandent des comptes c'est là
leur moindre défaut que faisiez-vous
autant chaud disent-ils au ministre des
impôts nuitées jour à tout venant je
dépensais quoi qu'il en coûte ne vous en
déplaise vous dépensiez j'en suis forte
et bien monsieur le ministre renflouer
maintenant
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Monique Lubin pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et républicain
vous avez la parole
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales madame la rapporteur messieurs
les rapporteurs monsieur le ministre
il faut une réponse systémique à la
nécessité de rendre au travailleur et
aux citoyens cette puissance d'agir que
constitue la possibilité d'assurer sa
subsistance de consommer de construire
son quotidien ainsi que sa place dans la
société et sa protection sociale
nous aurions donc espéré dans le projet
de loi que nous discutons aujourd'hui
une valorisation du travail une
clarification de ce qu'est le travail et
des droits qu'il apporte nous attendions
des mesures qui permettent de consolider
le salariat et notre système de
protection sociale
rien de tel dans ce texte qui ignore la
question salariale pourtant au cœur de
celle du pouvoir d'achat et je dirais
même que la réponse systémique du
gouvernement vire aussinisme vous jouez
de diversion au moyen de multiples
mesures dont certaines dépassent
formellement le champ des affaires
sociales pour finalement aggraver la
prédation à l'encontre de la sécurité
sociale
vous faites le choix délibéré d'un
revenu désocialisé et défiscalisé et
c'est sous la pression de la crise
inflationniste que les travailleurs pris
à la gorge se voient proposer la
substitution de la prime au salaire
parallèlement à une modération du coût
du travail c'est à dire des salaires
avec la prime de partage de la valeur
l'exceptionnelle devient donc la règle
cette prime pérennise en effet un
dispositif facultatif temporaire et
discrétionnaire
elle augmente le plafond de la prime
Macron pour atteindre 6000 euros ce
chiffre opère une diversion nous savons
en effet que malgré un plafond passé à
2000 euros depuis sa mise en place en
2019 le montant moyen de cette prime n'a
jamais dépassé 506 euros
par ailleurs en 2019 selon Lacosse les 2
millions de salariés bénéficiaires de la
prime représentait seulement
10,7% du total des salariés d'où le
cynisme
monsieur le ministre les Français ne
demandent pas l'aumône il demande des
salaires justes une protection sociale
de qualité et des conditions de travail
dignes dans le même temps et parce que
cela va de pair le gouvernement continue
à faire du dialogue social un simple
décor en renvoyant les partenaires
sociaux un statut de figurant
on atteste son choix de faire mine et
d'inciter les branches à la négociation
sur les salaires avec son article 4 qui
ne constitue en rien un soutien
suffisant au valorisation salariale
si les travailleurs pauvres et les
premiers de corvées sont ignorés ici
l'enjeu n'est pas seulement la
modération salariale il s'agit aussi de
programmer l'obsolescence du salariat et
des protections qu'il apporte
l'intéressement croissant à l'épargne
salariale voulue par le gouvernement et
de fait un dispositif d'évitement du
salaire qui participent de ce mouvement
il donne le pouvoir à l'employeur de
décider unilatéralement de mettre en
place ce dispositif dans les entreprises
de moins de 50 salariés en cas d'échec
des négociations ou en l'absence
d'institutions représentatives du
personnel
le texte fragilise le don la sécurité
sociale en la privant de ressources dans
le but toujours de relancer l'activité
économique le patrimoine que constitue
pour les Français les assurances
sociales est en effet dilapidé par le
gouvernement depuis longtemps je pense
au choix de faire porter à la sécurité
sociale la dette covid et au refus de
compenser le trou de 2 milliards 800
millions d'euros des mesures prises en
réponse à la crise des gilets jaunes
la revalorisation exceptionnelle de 4%
qui est une bonne chose mais par
ailleurs pas suffisante à améliorer le
tableau de votre texte elle ne fait en
effet qu’anticiper les revalorisations
de droit commun prévus d'octobre 2022 à
avril 2023 et elle ne suffira pas à
compenser la forte augmentation de
l'inflation évaluée par l'INSEE de 6 à
7% cette année
au registre des déceptions la majorité
du Sénat en boîte d'ailleurs le pas à
l'exécutif puisque peut-être inspiré par
le choix de l'Assemblée nationale de
mettre en place une monétisation des RTT
menaçantes pour les 35 heures elle a
choisi de baisser les cotisations
patronales au titre des heures
supplémentaires cette logique de
fragilisation de la sécurité sociale est
aussi à l'oeuvre avec la baisse pérenne
des cotisations des indépendants pour un
gain de 550 euros de revenus annuels ont
sacrifie la protection sociale des
travailleurs indépendants cela confirme
la marche vers l'ubérisation du travail
que nous dénonçons maintenant depuis
plusieurs années vous refusez l'idée
d'une grande conférence sur les salaires
qui auraient pour objectif d'amener les
employeurs à augmenter les salaires et
dans le même temps vous leur donnez les
outils pour contourner le salariat au
final nous savons tous qui seront les
perdants et la grande idée de loi sur le
pouvoir d'achat ne sera que le faune
d'une stratégie de fragilisation du
salariat cynisme toujours
merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
donner la parole maintenant à notre
collègue Jean-Baptiste Lemoine pour le
groupe du Rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants
vous savez la parole
merci beaucoup monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les présidents de
commission Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs monsieur ministre
mes chers
inédit comment et je crois que depuis
deux ans et demi nous l'avons vu combien
de fois nous sommes nous retrouvons ici
réunis par Le Mans gouvernement pour
prendre des mesures urgentes et
protégées nos compatriotes d'abord pour
les aider à tenir face à la crise
sanitaire et puis pour les aider à tenir
encore face aux conséquences de la
guerre en Ukraine et je crois que tous
ensemble nous avons
collectivement répondu présent de la
République les premiers ministres
gouvernement successifs l'Assemblée
nationale le Sénat les iconés peuvent en
témoigner comme sur tous vos territoires
les plans de soutien les plans de
relance l'État a été là l'État est là et
l'État sera là l'État a été là dès
l'automne dernier sans délai avec le
bouclier tarifaire qui était mis en
place pour limiter la hausse des coûts
de l'énergie pour les ménages pour les
petites entreprises pour les petites
communes l'État est là encore avec ce
texte nous déployons de nombreuses
protections nouvelles boucliers loyers
boucliers revenus bouclier social
bouclier énergie et tout cela les
Français en ont besoin tout de suite qui
justifient effectivement des travaux en
commission un rythme soutenu et je salue
nous rapporteurs comme tous les
collègues qui ont de vrai d'arrache-pied
l'État sera là en fin demain et
après-demain encore parce que au-delà de
l'aspect défensif des différents
boucliers des différents dispositifs je
crois que nous avons le devoir aussi
d'être offensif pour favoriser le
pouvoir de vivre je reprendrai et je
reviendrai sur cette expression qu'à
employé également Jean-Marie
vannerenberg dans l'immédiat car
l'urgence est là ce projet de loi est à
nos yeux trois fois nécessaire et c'est
pourquoi le groupe RDPI cher président
Patriat dira donc trois fois oui oui
pour juguler l'inflation et je note que
les Français sont mieux protégés que les
autres Européens oui pour mieux protéger
les consommateurs et oui pour assurer
notre prévisionnement énergétique
trois fois oui car ce texte porte en lui
des mesures très concrètes pour que le
travail paye mieux par exemple baisse
des cotisations pour les travailleurs
indépendants les conjoints
collaborateurs ajoutent très utile de
l'Assemblée nationale prime de partage
de la valeur prime d'activité
revalorisée et cet article 4 avec lequel
et bien nous souhaitons que nous
souhaitons rétablir avec Xavier Martin
lévrier parce qu'effectivement en finir
avec les minimas de branche inférieure
au SMIC et bien c'est aussi redonner du
pouvoir d'achat parce que parfois les
primes d'ancienneté sont calculées
là-dessus c'est une mesure utile
pertinente dont nous souhaitons la
rétroduction et puis parlant de droit du
travail j'ai une pensée aujourd'hui pour
Nicole brick il y a 5 jours pour jour
elle était là pour évoquer la réforme du
Code du travail voilà je tenais à le
dire aujourd'hui et puis ce texte porte
aussi des mesures très concrètes pour
que la solidarité nationale soit
toujours au rendez-vous par exemple avec
les revalorisations typées d'un certain
nombre de prestations familiales de
retraite d'invalidité le RSA est
naturellement la réforme ambitieuse de
la hache avec sa conjugalisation en
complément de sa revalorisation
solidarité nationale également pour
protéger ce qui est essentiel et
l'essentiel c'est par exemple le
logement à cet égard la revalorisation
des aPL dès le premier juillet couplé à
la limitation de la variation de l'IRL à
3 et demi pour cent est un soutien clair
pour nos compatriotes mais regardons de
près aussi la situation des Outre-mer
chez tany Mohamed cher Marie-Laure
finira parce que nous souhaitons ici au
groupe RDPI c'est une proposition de
Dominique Théophile et bien limité à
2,5% l'IRL outremer en termes de
progression maximale parce que il y a
aussi des diversités qui doivent être
prises en compte nous souhaitons aussi
protéger ce qui est essentiel pour les
commerçants leur commerce de la Côte
d'Or et justement à l'Isère ou à l'heure
pour là aussi faire en sorte que la
logique est bien de plafonnement de la
progression des loyers et bien et lieu
je me réjouis qu'un large à cœur a eu
lieu est atteint est atteint par les
parties prenantes
qui n'attend plus que l'onction
législative et puis nous avons également
de nombreuses dispositions qui vont
permettre d'éviter les dépenses inutiles
parce que les Français connaissent aussi
des injustices comment peut-on en
quelques secondes s'abonner cliquez
prendre un contrat et mettre parfois
plusieurs mois pour le résilier ça
c'était incompréhensible et donc nous
salons la mise en place de ce bouton
résiliation avec quelques propositions
d'aménagement également du texte pour
que il n'y ait pas de contraintes
excessive sur les très petites
entreprises qui ne sont pas forcément
équipées en matière numérique et ce
texte d'ailleurs en matière de
consommation s'attaque aux engagements
contractuels frauduleux vous le savez
ils sont en train hélas de galoper les
pratiques commerciales déloyales Martin
lévrier Frédéric puissat Corinne Ferret
pourrait en parler savamment notamment
sur certaines dérives observées sur le
CPF alors les pouvoirs de la DGCCRF
seront renforcés cette heureux de la
même façon que ces dispositions ont pu
être inscrites en durée puis il y a
aussi des mesures très concrètes en
matière énergétique avec le bouclier
avec des réponses pragmatiques
raisonnables qui permettront d'ailleurs
enfin qui seront compensés par des
dispositifs pour que en termes
d'émission en gaz à effet serre on reste
sur une logique de développement durable
je sais que c'est un sujet cher et à
Michel Dagbert et Frédéric marchand et
puis les aménagements relatifs à la
reine
s'ils ouvrent forcément un débat on peut
dire que l'arène aujourd'hui protège le
consommateur les entreprises et donc
mérite d'être conforté mais au-delà du
pouvoir d'acheter nous nous devons de
développer aussi ce pouvoir de vivre qui
était évoqué auparavant et pour
reprendre le titre d'impact établi par
de nombreux acteurs il ne suffit pas
juste de permettre de boucler les fins
de mois ayant plus d'ambition parce que
chaque française chaque Français doit
avoir plus que cela avoir un revenu
disponible décent car le revenu
disponible c'est vraiment ce qui vous
permet d'avoir de la liberté et cet élan
devenu trop souvent un luxe pour trop de
Français des classes modestes pour trop
de Français à des classes moyennes et
cette liberté
un luxe elle est essentielle et bien
comment faire faire en sorte que chacun
puisse avoir un travail c'est le
chantier du plein d'emploi monsieur le
ministre en mettant le paquet sur
l'éducation que chacun puisse avoir un
travail rémunérateur il a juste
considération c'est la juste
rémunération et pas seulement juste une
rémunération alors monsieur le ministre
nous serons à vos côtés pour défendre le
pouvoir d'achat et nous serons aussi
tout au long des prochains mois pour des
transformations pour que chacun a le
droit de vivre dans la dignité je vous
remercie
[Applaudissements]
je vais maintenant appeler notre
collègue Vanina
Pauly Gaga pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et territoires
vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues la fin
du quoiqu'il en coûte t'attendra à la
crise sanitaire s'ajoute une crise
économique et bientôt qui sait j'espère
me tromper se disant une crise
financière
la force économique au sortir des
confinements à provoqué des tensions sur
bon nombre de marché
dont ceux des matières premières des
énergies mais également des semis
conducteurs
cette situation inflationniste a été
encore aggravée par l'invasion russe en
Ukraine on entrant confrontation avec
l'Europe la Russie bouleverse
l'équilibre énergétique qui privait
la France qui compte pourtant parmi des
pays des moins touchés par l'inflation a
vu le niveau général de ces prix
d'augmenter de près de 6% lors des 12
derniers mois
cette situation a de lourdes
conséquences pour bon nombre de ménages
malgré les aides déjà accordées par
l'État elle aura un empaté de graves
conséquences sur nos finances publiques
mais chaque chose en son temps d'abord
d'urgence
et l'urgence c'est de faire en sorte que
le travail soit mieux revalorisé en
donnant planification à la prime de
pouvoir d'achat
j'estime cependant qu'elle ne doit pas
se substituer aux revenus et qu'un
encadrement strict devra garantir un
recours sans dévoiement à ce dispositif
à ce titre je défendrai plusieurs
amendements simplifions cet outil à la
dispositions des entreprises et aux
bénéfice des salariés pour renforcer son
efficacité
le travail déjà effectué en faveur des
professions libérales et des
micro-entrepreneurs me paraît tout aussi
essentiel notre pays a la chance de
pouvoir compter sur des forces vives
importantes et doivent préserver son
tissu d'entrepreneur la simplification
du cas de juridique de l'intéressement
est aussi à saluer la souplesse jouera
en faveur des salariés et des
entreprises
mais ce qui est aussi très urgent
monsieur le ministre c'est que nous
ayons une réflexion avancée sur notre
droit du travail il doit être simplifié
et adapté aux enjeux du siècle il doit
gagner en agilité et en flexibilité pour
les évolutions futures nous serons au
rendez-vous de discussion quand le temps
sera venu
l'autre grand défi que doivent relever
la France et ses partenaires européens
et celui de la souveraineté énergétique
l'Europe est condamnée à la dépendance
dans la mesure où elle doit importer les
matériaux nécessaires à la production de
ces énergies
cette dépendance n'est pas incompatible
avec sa souveraineté à la condition
qu'elle parvienne à s'approvisionner
auprès de sources diversifiées et sur
le gaz russe manquera cet hiver pour
compenser il convient notamment
d'importer davantage de gaz naturel
liquéfié ce dernier est pendant plus
cher et impose que la France doit
rapidement d'équipement nécessaire à son
exploitation
le parc nucléaire français ne suffira
pas en l'état à subvenir à nos besoins à
ce titre les évolutions concernant la
reine vont dans le bon sens
le nucléaire est donc une chance pour
notre pays et il faut le préserver mais
d'autre part vous le savez est
vieillissant les investissements seront
la clé de notre souveraineté énergétique
le nucléaire quel que soit sa forme EPR
SMR restera un atout de transition au
même titre que les énergies
renouvelables et notamment l'hydrogène
vers
sous réserve là encore pour le nucléaire
que nous sécurisions aussi notre
approvisionnement en uranium certaines
centrales à charbon devront
malheureusement être réactivés cette
situation ne serait être pérenne nous
devrons continuer de consolider notre
souveraineté énergétique dans les années
à venir tout en respectant nos propres
engagements je le rappelle dans la lutte
contre le dérèglement climatique
la sobriété et l'efficience seront deux
alliés majeurs
grâce notamment je le pense monsieur le
ministre a une plus forte
décentralisation de la production et de
la consommation des énergies
renouvelables cela passera par
l'innovation par la réindustrialisation
pour maîtriser en circuit court les
chaînes de valeur et booster la
décarbonation de notre économie ce
projet de loi très urgence c'est
pourquoi les membres du groupe Les
Indépendants soutiendront son adoption
nous devons cependant garder à l'esprit
que l'ensemble de ces mesures auront de
graves conséquences sur nos finances
publiques
la France doit s'assurer de bâtir son
avenir sur des bases solides je vous
remercie merci je vais m'abandonner la
parole à notre collègue Philippe mouillé
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre madame la Présidente sociale
madame la rapporteur mes chers collègues
ce texte représente la première partie
des mesures annoncées par le
gouvernement en faveur du pouvoir
d'achat des Français le Bel et faire
examinait la semaine prochaine
constituant son complément il s'agit de
réagir dans l'urgence à deux événements
majeurs la hausse brutale de l'inflation
et les difficultés d'approvisionnement
énergétique de la France
mais force est de constater que le
projet du gouvernement repose
essentiellement sur l'attribution
ponctuelle de chèque ce qui ne
représente pas une politique en soi je
m'attacherai à évoquer le volet social
du projet de loi
je note tout d'abord des mesures de pure
communication telles que le triplement
de la prime dénommée de partage de la
valeur mesure phares sont ces améliorer
le niveau de vie des Français son
montant pouvant aller jusqu'à 6000 euros
dans certains cas cependant le montant
moyen des sommes versées au titre de la
prime Macron s'est situé autour de 500
euros et cela n'a concerné que très peu
de travailleurs un actif sur cinq
même volonté d'affichage lorsque le
gouvernement appelle les branches
professionnelles à négocier sur les
salaires l'article 4 n'est guère
incitatif et si peu approprié à la
situation de très rares branches
concernées que notre commission a décidé
de le supprimer
c'est nous pouvons caquestrer aux aides
de silence atteints publics
revalorisation anticipée des retraites
baisse de cotisation sociale pour les
travailleurs indépendants nous
constatons également un saupoudrage de
moyens dont l'addition finit par grever
de façon alarmante les finances de
l'État après le long des épisodes de
crise sanitaire il faudrait sortir enfin
de la politique du continent coûte en
matière de dépenses publiques
il a été reproché à nos collègues
députés LR de proposer également des
solutions coûteuses cependant ils ont
fait des propositions claires pour
financer ces mesures notamment par des
économies importantes dans le
fonctionnement bien trop lourd de nos
administrations
nous proposons pour notre part dans le
PEL effet de lutter contre la fraude
sociale par la mise en place d'une carte
Vitale biométrique
notre logique politique est claire au
lieu d'une politique de l'assistanat
nous souhaitons privilégié la solidarité
et l'aide au travail
nous pensons que le pouvoir d'achat doit
garder son lien avec le travail et que
le travail doit être privilégié à
l'assistance ainsi nous avons souhaité
alléger la fiscalité et les chats
sociales qui pèsent sur les heures
supplémentaires suite à la
défiscalisation de 16h dont le plafond
était porté à 7500 euros notre
rapporteur Frédéric puissa dont je salue
la qualité du travail et
l'investissement sur ce texte a proposé
d'alléger les cotisations sociales des
entreprises d'au moins 20 salariés
renforçant ainsi l'attractivité du
dispositif
dans le périphérie nous avons obtenu du
gouvernement que les RTT puissent
racheter par les salariés qui souhaitent
travailler plus pour améliorer leur
pouvoir d'achat ce mesure devront être
définitives et pas seulement provisoire
comme le souhaite au gouvernement
concernant également les salariés notre
commission adopter un amendement
permettant exceptionnellement le
déblocage des sommes issus de la
participation et de l'intéressement
placé sur des plans d'épargne salariale
ces dispositions permettra de disposer
d'un pouvoir d'achat immédiat jusqu'à
10000 euros avant le 31 décembre
prochain
de même notre rapporteur a proposé
d'assouplir les règles encadrant
l'utilisation des titres restaurants
ceci pourront être utilisés pour les
achats alimentaires courants dans les
commerces de détails et les supermarchés
ce qui répond réellement à un vrai
besoin
ce sont autant de mesures qui auront un
impact direct sur le pouvoir d'achat
j'ajoute que je soutiendrai plusieurs
amendements dont je suis consignataire
l'un d'eux vise le pouvoir d'achat des
retraités en situation de cumul emploi
l'autre concerne l'article 4 du projet
de loi et la revalorisation du RSA et de
la location de solidarité spécifique
afin que celle-ci ne soit pas supérieur
à celle du point d'indice pour les
fonctionnaires nous ne pouvons en effet
adresser comme message aux Français que
des revenus d'assistance sont
privilégiés par rapport au revenu du
travail
je souffrais évoquer maintenant un
apport essentiel du texte qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur une usure
attendue de longue date par les
associations et les personnes en
situation de handicap qu'elle représente
bien entendu je parle de la
décongélisation du mode du calcul de la
location aux adultes handicapés il
s'agit de l'article 5 bis
je me réjouis particulièrement de ces
tissus en tant que rapporteur de la
proposition de loi que nous avions voté
le 9 mars 2021 sur tous les bancs de
notre haute assemblée vider ensuite de
la substance lors de la seconde lecture
par l'Assemblée nationale
le gouvernement alors s'opposait alors
fermement à la déconjugué les nations de
la hache allant jusqu'à recourir un vote
bloqué souvenez-vous
alors où le pouvoir d'achat des plus
fragiles et particulièrement menacé je
pense que l'esprit de solidarité doit
primer sur les règles technocratiques je
ne d'ailleurs que nous sommes finalement
parvenus à un accord sur ce dossier qui
dit depuis des années et que finalement
les défis des minima sociaux ne
s'écoulera pas pour autant
encore reste-t-il à adapter le
dispositif au cas par cas comme je
l'avais souligné lors de l'examen de la
proposition de loi la déconjuguer les
assure peut faire des perdants il s'est
laissé d'ailleurs de l'argument
principal opposé à notre demande
un mécanisme transitoire permettant de
conserver le bénéfice des règles de
calcul actuels dans les cas les plus
favorables a été trouvés et je m'en
réjouis toutefois comme l'indiqué notre
rapporteur fait des puissant une
précision est nécessaire pour les
bénéficiaires de la hache qui se
trouveront en situation de
renouvellement de leurs droits
de plus je regrette que ces dispositions
pour des raisons techniques ne puissent
entrer en vigueur avant le premier
octobre 203
je profite d'ailleurs de ces tribunes
pour indiquer que même si la décongué
des actions de la hache est une avancée
fondamentale une amélioration pour ces
bénéficiaires cela ne règle pas
complètement le débat sur l'autonomie
financière des personnes en situation de
handicap et je pense au grand sujet de
l'évolution de la prestation du
compensation du handicap ce n'est pas
l'objet de ce texte mais nous devrons
engager des travaux dans les prochaines
semaines sur ce sujet fondamental pour
une réforme globale en conclusion
monsieur le ministre le groupe
soutiendra le projet de loi sous réserve
du sort qui sera réservé à nous
amendements et à ceux de notre apporteur
je vous remercie pour votre attention
merci mon cher collègue
de donner la parole notre collègue Amel
gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centrices
[Applaudissements]
il y avait la parole
merci monsieur le président
collègue
explosion du prix de l'énergie et de
hausse constante du coup de la vie la
préservation du pouvoir d'achat des
Français et désormais plus qu'une
boussole c'est un impératif il faut
entendre la détresse et parfois la
colère de nos concitoyens difficultés à
boucler les fins de mois anxiété à
l'idée de faire le plein pour son
véhicule sacrifice au quotidien nous ne
pouvons pas rester sourd ni à fun face à
ces situations compliquées
face au projet de loi pour la protection
du pouvoir d'achat une question demeure
ce projet répond-il aux besoins des plus
fragiles va-t-il améliorer durablement
les conditions de vie ou de survie des
plus touchés par l'inflation la réponse
est non durablement non néanmoins avec
mes collègues du groupe de l'Union
centriste nous sommes persuadés que les
dispositions contenus dans ce projet de
loi sont quoi qu'il en soit les
bienvenus dans ce contexte difficile il
ne s'agit pas de donner un blanc sain au
gouvernement mais je je crois que dans
cette hémicycle nous devons faire primer
le bon sens et l'intérêt général à ce
titre nous salue nous saluons pardons la
revalorisation des minima sociaux la
résiliation facilité des abonnements
conclus par voie électronique le
plafonnement des loyers pour les ménages
et enfin la déconjugualisation de
l'Allocation Adulte handicapés qui
reconnaît enfin un statut pour l'adulte
en situation de handicap mais qu'en
est-il des aides ciblées afin d'aider
les Français qui en ont le plus besoin
on ne peut plus financer de manière
aveugle des aides généralisées en
continuant de creuser le déficit public
aide d'ailleurs souvent supporté par les
collectivités il est question ici de
justice sociale les politiques publiques
doivent cibler les plus fragiles pour
les soutenir durablement je pense à nous
aînés à nos étudiants aux familles
monoparentales au classement moyenne ce
qui doivent payer toujours plus pour
gagner de moins en moins ce texte est
également l'occasion d'aborder l'enjeu
de notre souveraineté énergétique une
véritable course contre la montre
s'engage pour éviter des ruptures
d'approvisionnement cet hiver en
électricité notamment vous proposez
quelques mesures mais qui ne répondent
pas à nos besoins grandissant et qui
contredisent même nos ambitions pour
répondre à l'urgence environnementale
c'est d'une vision long termeiste d'une
vision stratégique dont nous avons
besoin pour anticiper les défis de
demain pour notre pays nous avons besoin
également de constance dans notre
politique énergétique et
d'approvisionnement après avoir renoncé
au nucléaire a été annoncé il y a
quelques mois la construction de 6
réacteurs nucléaires ou en sommes-nous
de notre objectif de neutralité carbone
ce fameux objectif 2050 alors qu'est
annoncé aujourd'hui la réouverture de la
centrale à charbon de Saint-Avold
pour conclure nous formulons deux voeux
une nouvelle méthode de travail et un
cap stratégique qui redonnera confiance
à nos concitoyens à nos entreprises à
nos élus pour ce qui est de la méthode
de travail le quinquina qui s'ouvre de
vêtres celui de la co-construction
législative et d'un travail plus
collaboratif avec le Parlement avec les
collectivités avec les associations
d'élus pour l'instant c'est uniquement
celui de l'urgence nous ne pouvons pas
nous en satisfaire et il est primordial
de passer des paroles aux actes ici au
Sénat nous avons reçu le projet de loi
pouvoir d'achat vendredi 22 juillet pour
un examen commission lundi 25 juillet et
un passage en sciences publiques le 28
juillet comment pouvons-nous traiter en
48 heures des sujets aussi fondamentaux
deuxième vœu que nous formulons celui du
cap à donner nous appelons le
gouvernement à adopter des politiques de
long terme à donner plus de visibilité
aux urgences à répondre pardon urgences
d'aujourd'hui mais au besoin de demain 4
viendra-t-il en janvier 2023 pour nous
concitoyens lorsque les remises sur le
carburant ne seront plus appliqués
quelle garantie en matière
d'approvisionnement en électricité
pourriez-vous offrir aux entreprises qui
envisageraient de s'installer en France
quelle réponse apporterez-vous aux
collectivités qui s'interrogent sur la
faisabilité de leur projet
d'investissement face à l'augmentation
toujours croissante de leurs dépenses de
fonctionnement et à la baisse de leurs
recettes des questions concrètes qui
appellent des réponses précises je vous
remercie de votre écoute merci monsieur
le donner maintenant la parole à notre
collègue Franck montoger pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et républicain
vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègue en matière de
logement et du point de vue des usagers
les plus modestes donc les plus touchés
par l'inflation les dispositions visant
à contenir les hausses de loyer ne sont
pas assez fortes nous propose nous
proposerons un IRL plafonné à 1,5% sur
tout le territoire national pour mémoire
la diminution des appels vous a permis
de faire l'économie de 12 milliards
d'euros lors du quinquennat précédent
les mesures que vous proposez dans ce
texte représente seulement 168 millions
d'euros disons-le sans engage les
dispositions de titres de relatives à la
protection du consommateur qu'elle soit
relative à la résiliation des contrats
ou à la lutte contre les pratiques
commerciales illicites bien
qu'opportunes sont de portées réduites
nous vous proposerons par amendement de
les améliorer les mesures du title 3
traitant de la souveraineté énergétique
pour autant qu'elle soit nécessaire
révèle les faiblesses et les
contradictions de la politique
énergétique française
la crise aura permis de mesurer la
tension qu'il faut en permanence porter
à l'outil de stockage de souterraines de
gaz outils stratégique cylinais dont la
dimension de politique nationale a été
oubliée ou mes estimée en même temps
qu'elle porte atteinte à la crédibilité
de la parole publique la nécessité de
prévoir la réouverture de centrale à
charbon pose pour nous la question des
conditions sociales du réemploi et de la
formation des personnels nécessaires
quant à l'accès régulier régulier à
l'électricité nucléaire historique il
confirme par ses conséquences ce que
nous rapporte sénatoriaux récents ont
mis en évidence l'affaiblissement
régulier de DF jusqu'à sa mise en péril
au regard des investissements
considérables à financer dans le cadre
de la Stratégie nationale barcaba
carbone et de la programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie que nous
aurons à actualiser prochainement en
matière de climat la France doit être au
rendez-vous de ces engagements après
années de perdu et deux condamnations
pour inaction climatique au-delà des
évolutions nécessaires de la reine que
porte le texte et que nous soutiendrons
comme la limitation de volume à
centerawattheure ou à 25% de la
production nucléaire annuelle au prix
actualisée de 49,5 euros du
mégawattheure nous demandons d'anticiper
son extinction et sa suppression totale
tant la reine c'est jusqu'ici révélée
comme un instrument de pillage et donc
d'affaiblissement d'EDF au profit de ses
concurrents nous vous proposerons un
amendement qui proportionne les cessions
au titre de la reine à la situation
financière des entreprises dont
certaines ont vu leur profit exploser
j'ai en tête totale en particulier du
fait de la crise géopolitique nous
demanderons aussi qu'un bilan objectif
du marché de l'électricité soit réalisé
à quoi le principe de libre concurrence
non faussée a-t-il conduit pour les
consommateurs français pour l'appareil
industriel français nous avons aussi que
le Parlement en l'occurrence le Sénat
n'a pas à sécuriser juridiquement le
décret de passage à
saint-vincerawatts que le gouvernement
français n'a pas soumis au conseil
social de l'entreprise ni notifié
formellement à la Commission européenne
pourquoi Monsieur le Ministre avoir
procédé de la sorte en toute
connaissance de fait d'une aide d'État
dont l'absence de notification fragilise
aujourd'hui les fournisseurs alternatifs
il est plus jeune urgent de reconsidérer
autour du groupe public EDF l'ensemble
du dispositifs de gestion de
l'électricité en France par une QAG
japonais il y a quelques jours le
gouvernement à ouvrir un débat public et
parlementaire à propos du projet
national pour EDF le débat 50-1 que
propose madame la Première ministre ne
suffira pas nous demandons le vote d'une
loi spécifique sur le projet industriel
social et environnemental d'EDF et le
plus rapidement possible le gouvernement
devra réunir réussir la réforme des
structures des tarifs de l'électricité
qui doivent reposer sur les coûts
complets de long terme de l'ensemble du
parc de production au final ce texte
sera insuffisant pour répondre aux
besoins élémentaires de millions de
Français le pouvoir de vivre de nos
concitoyens sera au coeur de nos
propositions dans les prochaines lois de
finance je vous remercie merci mon chers
collègues
je vais maintenant donner la parole à
notre collègue Pierre Cuypers pour le
groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
vous avez la parole mon cher collègue
merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre
madame la présidente des affaires
sociales Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs mes chers collègues
nous l'attendions nous l'attendions ce
texte sur le pouvoir d'achat promis
depuis bien des semaines il est enfin
inscrit à l'ordre du jour de notre
assemblée malgré les délais très courts
pour l'examiner au Sénat
je voudrais rappeler qu'à la veille du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle
66% des Français cité la question du
pouvoir d'achat comme l'enjeu principal
de cette élection selon le baromètre
Opinion Way
le gouvernement nous présente donc comme
d'autres l'aurait fait d'ailleurs un
projet de loi censé atténuer les effets
de l'inflation et de la crise
énergétique tout en contenant les
déficits publics
car oui la côte d'alerte monsieur le
ministre sur les finances publiques et
dépassé depuis bien longtemps le Sénat a
l'air très clairement sur le sujet sans
être entendus des derniers gouvernements
successifs il faut bien l'avouer la
dette publique dépasse désormais 2900
milliards d'euros et par conséquent
c'est bien l'avenir des générations
futures de nos enfants que nous obéirons
ainsi aussi il faut trouver la ligne de
crête entre le soutien à ceux de nos
concitoyens qui souffrent le plus de la
situation actuelle et la nécessité de ne
pas alourdir la dette publique pour
préparer l'avenir et la nécessaire
transition écologique qui a impose des
investissements massifs
alors que nous propose le gouvernement
d'abord un texte insuffisamment
ambitieux avec des mesures qui peuvent
sembler anecdotiques au vu de la
situation comme la possibilité de
résilier par voie électronique les
contrats souscrits en ligne ensuite un
texte qui n'a rien de structurel j'en
crois pour preuve les mesures concernant
le plafonnement de la hausse des loyers
c'est clairement ignoré les solutions de
long terme pour favoriser la
construction de nouveaux logements car
c'est bien le manque de logement qui
explique aujourd'hui la tension sur les
loyers enfin un texte en contradiction
avec certaines de nos politiques
publiques
particulièrement dans le domaine
énergétique comme ça a été évoqué à
plusieurs reprises nous légiférons
aujourd'hui pour ouvrir les centrales à
charbon après avoir décidé de les fermer
et surtout après des années d'hésitation
et de contradiction sur le développement
du nucléaire
nous allons aussi importer des
hydrocarbures après avoir abandonné la
filière nationale et fragilisée les
filières françaises des carbonées
aussi je voudrais m'attarder sur le
sujet énergétique car il est essentiel
il est essentiel parce qu'il concerne
tous les budgets de budgets de tous les
Français et de nos entreprises je
comprends je comprends l'urgence de la
situation mais je déplore le manque de
vision en la matière
restaurer la souveraineté énergétique de
la France
nécessitera d'être cohérent dans les
choix effectués et en la matière nous
pouvons regretter que cela n'est pas été
le cas ces 10 dernières années
derrière les articles de projet de loi
de l'arrêt sur la reine et sur l'avenir
d'EDF qui se pose et nous avons maintes
fois eu l'occasion de vous alerter
monsieur le ministre sur le sujet et
l'ensemble du gouvernement d'ailleurs
alors monsieur le ministre vous parlez
d'une nationalisation pourquoi pas mais
pourquoi faire pour changer quoi
cela ne répond pas aux difficultés du
groupe et notamment au mur
d'investissement auquel EDF doit faire
face
nous prenons donc depuis longtemps un
mixte énergétique décarboné autour du
nucléaire et ce dans un bouquet
d'énergie le rapport de nos collègues
grémillais Moga et Michaud a encore
récemment déploré l'affaiblissement de
la filière ainsi que ses perspectives
très complexes ils ont fait des
propositions pour relancer l'énergie
nucléaire et promouvoir l'hydrogène bas
carbone dont le gouvernement devrait
bien s'inspirer mais nous prenons
également le développement des énergies
vertes je pense à l'eau le vent le
soleil la biomasse la biogaz rien
monsieur le ministre rien mes chers
collègues ne doit être négligé pour
atteindre la neutralité carbone j'ai
d'ailleurs présidé il y a peu de la
mission d'information sur la
méthanisation nous avons là aussi les
pistes utiles pour favoriser la
transition et la souveraineté
énergétique si nous nous donnons les
moyens de structurer la filière et de
simplifier je dis bien de simplifier
l'ensemble des procédures l'actualité
nous l'impose plus que
au final le texte que nous examinons
aujourd'hui me paraît très décevant même
s'il comporte des mesures positives que
je salue et que mon collègue Philippe
Meunier a eu l'occasion de citer tout à
l'heure alors monsieur le ministre au
lieu de faire des chèques sans provision
comme le fait le gouvernement depuis des
années le groupe les républicains lui
veut muscler le texte avec des mesures
pérennes avec des mesures qui améliorent
le pouvoir d'achat des Français le
pouvoir d'achat des salariés et des
entreprises et surtout avec des mesures
d'économie car on ne peut plus ignorer
le problème de la dette comme je
l'expliquais précédemment je souhaite
chers amis chers collègues que les
débats qui souffrent ce matin
contribuent à donner plus d'ambition au
texte ce dont je ne doute pas car c'est
bien l'ADN du Sénat je vous remercie
merci
sur le ministre vous souhaitiez répondre
aux orateurs
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la présidente Madame la
rapporteur quelques mots en réponse au
différents intervenants de la discussion
générale en étant bref puisque les
articles de toute manière nous
permettront d'aller au fond des débats
je vais simplement souligner une
remarque que j'ai déjà faite en propos
liminaire pour dire que nous nous
abordons cette semaine de texte ici le
texte pouvoir d'achat le texte de loi de
finance rectificative ce qui démontre
évidemment l'enchevêtrement de certaines
dispositions et ce qui va nous amener et
ça
s'entendait dans les différentes
interventions à discuter de disposition
dans ce texte de disposition relevant du
PLF voir de textes réglementaires avec
parfois quelques renvois je pense par
exemple à la question des heures
supplémentaires puisque je le disais le
relèvement du plafond d'exonération a
été inscrit en PLFR et nous paraît plus
logique que si débat elle doit y avoir
dans ce texte dans cette semaine pardon
sur les heures supplémentaires cela
puisse se faire avec la loi de finance
rectificative
souligner aussi que nous sommes
collectivement face à deux injonctions
paradoxales à l'aube de l'examen de ce
texte la première touche au calendrier
le calendrier d'examens du texte nous
avons fait le choix de présenter ce
texte au Parlement dans les tous
premiers jours de la nouvelle session
parlementaire de la nouvelle législature
de l'Assemblée nationale derrière le
texte pourtant certaines dispositions en
matière d'état d'urgence sanitaire cela
mène effectivement un rythme rapide et
le rythme que le Sénat a connu a été
d'autant plus rapide que les débats
l'Assemblée nationale ont duré un peu
plus longtemps que ce que nous avions
imaginé précédemment l'injonction est un
peu paradoxale puisque nombreux ont été
ce parmi vous disant attendre avec
impatience le texte et à regretter que
nous puissions nous devions l'examiner
très vite mais cela fait malheureusement
partie de l'actualité et certainement de
quelques habitudes que nous avons au
Parlement français la deuxième
injonction se retrouvait paradoxale se
retrouvait dans les propos du dernier
intervenant avec de manière assez
marquée une volonté de beaucoup de
veiller au Cap en matière de finances
publiques de veiller à ce que les
objectifs soient tenus et dans le même
temps le regret de mesure qui n’iraient
pas assez loin qui ne serait pas assez
massive au risque que la massification
ou l'ambition supplémentaire se
traduisent aussi par des dépenses il y a
beaucoup d'intervenants beaucoup
d'interventions pardon qui ont porté sur
des questions relatives à l'énergie
relative au logement ou encore relative
à des questions de consommation je
laisserai à l'occasion du débat mais mes
collègues directement concernés en
Espagne Olivier Klein ou encore Olivier
agrégoire a porté les éléments et
participer au débat qui
vont qui vont vous animer je voudrais
simplement dire sur le sujet de
l'énergie que je partage les propos de
Madame la rapporteur au début de notre
séance concernant l'aspect humain qui
entoure la réouverture provisoire la
relance provisoire de l'activité de la
centrale de Saint-Avold en Espagne le
dirham plus précisément que moi ce n'est
pas une décision prise de gaieté de cœur
c'est une décision prise pour
l'approvisionnement énergétique elle est
temporaire elle sera compensée pour ce
qui concerne les émissions carbone et
nous demandons effectivement aux
salariés de cette centrale charbon de
Saint-Avold sur la base du volontariat
de participer à cette relance dans des
conditions que l'article 15 vise à
sécuriser puisque l'article 15 n'a qu'un
objectif sécuriser l'intégralité des
éléments du PSE et du plan de
reclassement tel qu'il a été négocié
pour que cette reprise d'activité
n'entraîne aucune perte des droits
négociés par les salariés cela n'enlève
rien à la dimension humaine que Madame
la rapporteur évoqué ce sont des
salariés qui en fait face à des
procédures de reclassement de
licenciement et qui nous demandons de
revenir en activité et humainement nous
devons tous éveiller en avoir une grande
confiance une grande conscience je
termine par un dernier point monsieur le
Président deux derniers points
pardonnez-moi le premier pour dire que
les trois points de divergence que j'ai
évoqués dans mon propos liminaire reste
évidemment sur
la question des heures supplémentaires
mais ça relève plus de la méthode et du
texte concerné sur la question de
l'article 4 ou encore sur la question de
la pérennité des dispositifs que nous
proposons en matière de partage de la
valeur nous devrons veiller je crois à
ce que ce que nous faisons autour de ces
sujets là dans ce texte comment payer
les faire nos berbère pas l'avenir j'ai
beaucoup entendu évoquer la question de
la démonétisation des heures
supplémentaires tels qu'adoptées à
l'Assemblée nationale adopté avec une
échéance cette échéance c'est aussi
penser pour être compatible avec le
projet de compte épargne temps universel
donc gardons aussi en tête la
possibilité d'avancer sur certains
chantiers je pense que sur tout le reste
et peut-être même sur ces sujets là de
nombreuses améliorations et de nombreux
consensus peuvent naître à l'occasion de
la discussion et j'en suis tout à fait
ravi et enfin le tout dernier point
c'est
pardonné pardonnerait de prendre cette
minute supplémentaire monsieur le
Président c'est pour m'associer à
l'hommage rendu par le sénateur Runner
hunberg à Frédéric sève ce militant ce
cadre extrêmement important et essentiel
de enfdt mais surtout cet acteur
essentiel du dialogue social ne vous
inquiétez brutalement cette semaine et
c'était justice de lui rendre hommage et
de rappeler sa mémoire monsieur le
sénateur
merci monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues la discussion générale est
close
nous passions la discussion du texte de
la commission
nous allons poursuivre jusqu'à 13h à
moins que vous
la Présidente je fais ce que vous
souhaitez
une commission à 14h20 pour voir des
amendements de récents
mais alors nous allons suspendre mais
auparavant je veux informer le sida que
des candidatures pour sierger aussi de
l'éventuelle commission mixte paritaire
chargée de proposer un texte sur les
dispositions restant en discussion sur
ce projet de loi ont été publiés ces
candidatures seront ratifiées si la
présidence n'a pas reçu d'opposition
dans le délai d'une heure prévue par
notre règlement j'informe également
le Sénat que la commission mixte
paritaire chargée d'élaborer un texte
sur les dispositions restantes en
discussions du projet de loi radifiant
l'ordonnance
qui porte le numéro
20 21 16 05 du 8 décembre 2021 étant la
fonction publique des communes de
Polynésie française
certaines dispositions statutaires
relatives à la fonction publique
territoriale et parvenu à l'adoption
d'un texte commun
je vais maintenant donc suspendre la
séance elle sera reprise je vous
consulte madame la Présidente à 14h30
pour la suite de l'examen de ce texte la
séance est suspendue